ओके अ आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ अ
एम आई ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल गाइस एक बार मुझे
बता दीजिए सभी लोग ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ
सही आ रही है क्या आप लोगों को एक बार
बताइए मुझे प्लीज चैट में बता दीजिए
आज थोड़ी आपकी आपकी क्लास जल्दी स्टार्ट
हो गई है। बट एक बार चैट में बता दीजिए
जल्दी से।
इफ ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ सही आ रही है तो
लेट मी नो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सही है। ऑडिबल ओके
ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] गुड
इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी।
अ वेरी गुड इवनिंग। वेरी नमस्ते टू
एवरीबॉडी।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] चलिए
अ
ओके। हर हर महादेव भाई। चलिए। सो आज की जो
क्लास है हम स्टार्ट करेंगे। बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग क्लास आज होने वाली है। और आज
का टाइमिंग भी थोड़ा सा चेंज्ड है।
टाइमिंग वैसे तो 7:00 pm पे होती है। बट
आज हम थोड़ा पहले आ चुके हैं। 1 घंटे पहले
हमने क्लास को स्टार्ट किया है। इस वजह से
हो सकता है कि कुछ लोग अटेंड ना कर पाएं।
मतलब उनको पता ही ना चले। थोड़ा लेट पता
पता चले। पॉसिबल है। तो क्योंकि आज 7:00
बजे से क्लास होती तो शायद प्रॉब्लम आते।
तो अभी हमने
6:00 बजे से स्टार्ट कर लिया है। लेट्स
वेट फॉर सम टाइम सो दैट एवरीबॉडी अ जॉइंस
द सेशन हियर।
देखो अभी आते-आते क्वेश्चन पूछने लगते
हैं। और कितनी क्लास होगी भाई? पढ़ते जाओ
यार। पढ़ते जाओ। थोड़ी बहुत क्लासेस और बची
हैं। वो हो जाएंगी। फिर कंप्लीट। आते-आते
क्वेश्चन यही है कि
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
चलो। ओके ग्रेट। चलिए अच्छी बात है गाइस।
सो वी आर गोइंग टू स्टार्ट एंड टुडे सेशन
इज जस्ट अमेजिंग सेशन। बिलीव मी सोर के
बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं बहुत जोर-जोर से।
ठीक है? क्योंकि सोर को अगर जोर से आप
नहीं पढ़ेंगे तो आपको मजा नहीं आएगा और
आपको जो है आप अधूरे एसोसिए एनालिस्ट
बनेंगे। फिर पूरे नहीं बन पाएंगे। सोर को
आप कर लेंगे तो आप पूरे एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट
बन जाएंगे। क्योंकि आपने इडीआर कर लिया
है। आपने स्प्लंक कर लिया है। एसआईएम कर
लिया है। तो सोर क्यों छोड़ दें? सोर को
तो हम करेंगे ही। राइट? सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बहुत बढ़िया।
चलिए। सो बिफोर वी स्टार्ट द सोर
चलिए अच्छी बात है।
हां। बिफोर वी स्टार्ट द सोर
लेट्स गेट अ बिट ऑफ बोर। सबसे पहले आपको
एक काम करना होता है। मैं आपको बता देता
हूं। कुछ लोग यहां चैट में बोल रहे थे सर
WhatsApp का ग्रुप फुल हो चुका है। तो
हमने ग्रुप के लिंक्स को चेंज कर दिया है।
तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अभी आप
YouTube पे डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube
चैनल ओपन कर लीजिएगा। लाइव सेक्शन में चले
जाइएगा और किसी भी एसओसी के प्रीवियस
वीडियोस को ओपन करके इसको पॉज कर दीजिएगा
आराम से।
एंड यहां डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइएगा। तो
यहां पे आपको एक WhatsApp चैनल का लिंक
मिलेगा और एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का मिलेगा
लिंक। ठीक है? WhatsApp चैनल पे आइएगा।
हमारा लगभग 13,000 लोग जुड़े हैं। हमारे
साइड से कोई भी अपडेट सबसे पहले आपको
WhatsApp चैनल के ऊपर ही मिलती है। हमारी
कंपनी से रिगार्डिंग क्लासेस एवरीथिंग जो
भी चीजें होती है ना ओवरऑल इसी में मिलती
है। तो इसको जरूर फॉलो कीजिएगा। फ्री ऑफ़
कॉस्ट है। दूसरा आपको एसओसी का ग्रुप
मिलेगा जो कि फुल नहीं है क्योंकि यह
लेटेस्ट दूसरा ग्रुप हमने क्रिएट करा है
और इसकी लिंक्स भी अपडेट कर दिए हैं सारे
वीडियोस में। तो आपको अपडेटेड लिंक्स मिल
जाएंगे। आप इसमें जॉइ कर सकते हैं। ये
ग्रुप ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा। एसओसी से
रिलेटेड जितने रिसोर्सेज हैं, जो भी नोट्स
हैं, जो भी चीजें हैं, सब इसी ग्रुप में
आएंगी और कहीं नहीं आती है। ठीक है? इसको
जॉइ कर लीजिएगा। Lindin पे आप मुझे फॉलो
कर सकते हैं। ये Lindin का हैंडल है मेरा।
मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। 13,000 लोग
मुझसे कनेक्ट हो चुके हैं अभी तक। आप भी
मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। मुझसे इंटरेक्ट
कर सकते हैं। साथ ही
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] में Lindin
पे आप सर्च करेंगे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स अगर तो
हमारे डिफ़्रोनिक्सic साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
Lindin पेज आपको मिल जाएगा। आप इसको जरूर
से जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा क्योंकि इस पेज
पर हमारी कंपनीज़ के तरफ से सारी अपडेट्स
आपको मिल जाती है। हमारी कंपनी का जो भी
आगे हम चीजें करने वाले हैं, जो भी हम
स्टेप्स लेने वाले हैं एज अ स्टार्टअप
क्या-क्या चीजें हम कर रहे हैं। क्या कोई
ऑफर हो गई, कोई गिव अवे हो गया, कोई किसी
भी तरह का ल्च हो गया, सब आपको यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देखने को मिल
जाता है। यह हमारे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
Instagram पेज है। यह आप कभी भी बहुत
लोगों ने नाम से इधर-उधर बना रखा है। देख
लीजिएगा यहां पे हमने इसीलिए टिक मार्क ले
लिया है। ब्लू टिक ले लिया है फाइनली पहले
नहीं था हमारे अब हमने ले लिया है ताकि
कोई मिमिक ना कर पाए इस चीज की
इंपपर्सनेशन ना कर पाए तो आप आके यहां पे
फॉलो कर सकते हैं लगभग 500 लोग अभी हमसे
जुड़े हुए हैं यहां इनेशनल रील कंटेंट्स
के लिए इस पेज को आप फॉलो कर लीजिए ये
मेरा पर्सनल Instagram प्रोफाइल है आप इस
पे आके मुझसे कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं जुड़
सकते हैं [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यह
हमारा जो डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
एक्स पेज है वो आप आके फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
यहां पे भी आपको चीजें मिलने मिलेंगी बहुत
सारी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मिलेंगी ये हमारी
वेब वेबसाइट है। इस पे आप ये नंबर दिया
हुआ है। इस पे आप हमसे किसी भी तरह की
क्वेरी, किसी भी तरह का क्वेश्चन हो इस पे
मैसेज कर लीजिएगा। दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब बिफोर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] स्टार्टिंग
टुडेज़ क्लास। ठीक है? नमस्ते। नमस्ते।
नमस्ते। बिफोर स्टार्टिंग टुडेेस क्लास,
मैं आपको एक चीज बताना चाहता हूं। मैंने
पिछली जो क्लास ली थी स्प्लंक का गाइड और
गाइड टू स्प्लंक। ये क्लास में मैंने आप
लोगों को एक टास्क दिया था। उस टास्क में
मैंने आपको बताया था कि ये जो ट्राई हैकमी
का रूम है स्प्लंक एक्सप्लोरिंग एसएल ठीक
है इस रूम को आपको कंप्लीट करना था एज अ
टास्क आई डोंट नो आप लोगों में से कितने
लोगों ने इसको कंप्लीट किया यह एक फ्री
रूम है पेड रूम नहीं है तो प्लीज इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट अगर जिन लोगों ने नहीं करा है
इसको जरूर कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा यह आपके लिए
बहुत बेनिफिशियल होगा बीइंग अगर आप अपने
आपको एक प्रोफेशनल बनते हैं बोलते हैं एक
जॉब रेडी प्रोफेशनल बोलना चाहते हैं तो
इसको कंप्लीट करना जरूरी है यह मैंने कवर
नहीं करा था क्योंकि फ्री रूम थी। तो
मैंने दूसरी चीजें कवर करी थी। कांसेप्ट्स
और चीजें बताई थी आपको पूरा। बट इस रूम को
जरूर कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है? अब मुझे एक बात
बताइए आप लोगों में से कितने लोगों ने इस
रूम को कंप्लीट कर लिया है लास्ट क्लास के
बाद से। ईमानदारी ऑनेस्टली से बताइए। चैट
में सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए। जिनका कंप्लीट
हुआ है उनका वो भी बताइए। जिनका नहीं हुआ
है वो भी बताइए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सर आपके वाईटी चैनल के बारे में एक वीक
पहले पता चला। मैंने 26 वीडियो देखी है।
अरे वाह एक एक वीक में 26 वीडियो देख ली
है। सही है। बट थोड़ा धीरे-धीरे देखो और
प्रैक्टिस करो साथ में।
आई एम नॉट गेटिंग रिस्पों्ससेस फ्रॉम
एवरीबॉडी। प्लीज रिसोंड। सभी लोग प्लीज
रिसोंड कीजिए। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट कि रिसोंड
कीजिए सभी लोग। कितने लोगों ने कंप्लीट
किया है? कितने लोगों ने नहीं किया है? इस
रूम को।
ठीक है? चलिए आज की क्लास स्टार्ट करते
हैं। कुछ लोगों ने कंप्लीट किया है। कुछ
लोगों ने नहीं भी किया है। आज की क्लास
स्टार्ट करते हैं। आज हम बेसिकली
सोर के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं बहुत
जोर-जोर से क्योंकि सोर इज वेरी वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक आपके एसओसी के लिए। अब
देखो सोर एक इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक भी है और
सोर से आप थोड़ा डर भी जाएंगे। आपको डराने
वाला भी टॉपिक है। अह अब यू मस्ट बी
थिंकिंग कि सर डराने वाला कैसे? मतलब
डरेंगे क्यों हम शोर से? देखो एक तो
अलग-अलग टूल्स आते हैं। राइट? अलग-अलग
टूल्स अटैक्स को मतलब अलर्ट करने के लिए,
अटैक्स के बारे में
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
उनके बारे में बताने के लिए, मिटिगेट करने
के लिए, अलग-अलग चीजें होती हैं। अलग-अलग
टूल्स भी आती हैं। राइट? तो उसमें से
ईडीआर वगैरह भी है आपका। फिर एसआईएम आया
कि सारे लॉक्स को एक जगह पे एक पैनल पर
लाओ और उन पे प्रोसेसिंग करो, एनालाइज
करो, उनको देखो
एक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] स्ट्रक्चरर्ड
वे में सारे लॉक्स को रखो और फिर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उस पे आगे जो
भी इन्वेस्टिगेशन जो भी चीजें उस पे करनी
है वो आगे की प्रोसेससेस करो एज अ एसओसी
एनालिस्ट। अब आ गया आपका सोर। सोर बेसिकली
सिक्योरिटी ऑकेेस्ट्रेशन
ऑटोमेशन एंड रिस्पांस। यह एक तरह का
एक तरह का टूल है। एक तरह का प्लेटफार्म
बोल लीजिए, टूल बोल लीजिए, व्हाटएवर यू
कैन से। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एक
तरह का ऐसा टूल है जिसका इस्तेमाल करके आप
सारी चीजों को ऑटोमेट कर सकते हैं। मैनुअल
करने की जरूरत नहीं है। जो अभी तक जो
हमारा एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट जो अभी तक
मैनुअली चीजें कर पा कर रहा था। मोस्टली
चीजें वह अब मोस्टली चीजें ऑटोमेट हो
जाएंगी सोर के थ्रू। यानी कि अगर सोर को
कंबाइन कर दिया जाए एसआईएम में तो यह एक
बहुत ही डेडली कॉम्बिनेशन हो जाता है। एंड
हर चीज को ऑटोमेट
कर दिया जाता है। हर चीज को ऑटोमेट
एवरीथिंग फ्रॉम स्टार्टिंग टू एंड। अब
आपके दिमाग में यह सवाल आ सकता है कि फिर
एसओसी एल1 की क्यों जरूरत है? व्हाई
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देयर इज द
नीड ऑफ़ SOCL1? तो जरूरत है। जरूरत इसलिए
है क्योंकि बहुत सारी कॉम्प्लेक्स कंडीशंस
में सोर काम नहीं करता है। जहां लॉजिक्स
की जरूरत होती है। कॉम्प्रिहेंसिव
स्टेप्स कुछ लॉजिकल स्टेप्स लेने होते
हैं। वहां पे सोर काम नहीं करता है। वहां
एक ह्यूमन एनालिस्ट ही है चाहिए। और सारी
चीजें होने के बाद भी वेरिफिकेशन जो है वो
ह्यूमन एनालिस्ट ही करते हैं। उसको फाइनल
जो वेरीफाई करते हैं वो एनालिस्ट ही करते
हैं। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अप्रूव
फाइनल एनालिस्ट ही करते हैं। तो देयर आर
मल्टीपल थिंग्स जहां पे एनालिस्ट का होना
बहुत जरूरी है। अदरवाइज ये चीजें सही से
काम नहीं करेंगी। ठीक है? बहुत सारी फिर
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स हो जाएंगी। बहुत सारी
दिक्कतें आ जाएंगी। देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़
थिंग्स। तो इसलिए एनालिस्ट का होना बहुत
जरूरी है एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट का भी। ठीक है?
चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यहां पे सोर को समझते हैं। देखो ये जो
टॉपिक्स मैं आपको करा रहा हूं ये टॉपिक्स
ऐसे ही कराए जाते हैं। पहली चीज आप लोग
ध्यान में रख लीजिएगा। इस चीज को इस बात
को ध्यान में रखिएगा। जो टॉपिक मैं जैसे
करा रहा हूं इसको ऐसे ही सिखाया जाता है
और ऐसे ही कराया जाता है। इसका कोई और
तरीका नहीं होता है। अगर आप में से कई लोग
ऐसे होंगे बिगिनर्स होंगे जो सोचते होंगे
कि सर इसका कुछ दिख नहीं रहा है मुझे
प्रैक्टिकल वगैरह-वगैरह या कुछ ऐसा। तो जो
कांसेप्ट्स और जिस तरीके की चीजें टूल को
मैं आपको विजुअलाइज करा रहा हूं लैब के
थ्रू जिस तरीके से हैंड्स ऑन करा रहा हूं
वही सेम चीजें आप यूज़ करेंगे जब आप एक
कंपनी में जाएंगे एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल1
पोजीशन पे और आपको सारी चीजें आती रहेंगी।
तो बिल्कुल टेंशन फ्री होके बेफिक्र होके
आप क्लासेस को ऐसे ही एज़ इट इज़ कंटिन्यू
कीजिए एंड ट्रस्ट कीजिए थोड़ा सा बिलीव
कीजिए एंड पढ़िए। पढ़ते रहिए। आपको अच्छा
रिजल्ट मिलेगा एट द एंड ऑफ दिस ट्रेन। ठीक
है? ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब
यहां पे एसओ एआर सिक्योरिटी ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन
ऑटोमेशन एंड रिस्पांस। ये इसका फुल फॉर्म
होता है इज अ टूल
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] दैट यूनिफाइस
ऑल द सिक्योरिटी टूल्स यूज्ड इन अ एसओसी।
अब एसओसी में जितने भी सिक्योरिटी टूल्स
यूज़ होते हैं, उन सबको एक जगह कलेक्ट करके
रखना सोर का काम है। एक जगह सबको कर देता
है सोर। सोर क्या करता है? एक जगह सबको कर
देता है। विद सोर एसओसी एनालिस्ट्स डू नॉट
नीड टू स्विच बिटवीन एसआईएम, ईडीआर,
फायरवॉल एंड अदर सिक्योरिटी टूल्स। सोर के
साथ क्या होगा? प्लीज फोकस हियर। चैट मैं
अभी नहीं देख रहा हूं। तो आप लोग इधर फोकस
कर लीजिए। अभी पढ़ लीजिए पहले। लास्ट में
चैट का डिस्कशन कर लेंगे। ठीक है? सोर के
साथ आपको अलग-अलग
जो टूल्स हैं, अलग-अलग जो प्लेटफॉर्म्स
हैं, जो टूल्स हैं, उनको यूज़ करने की
जरूरत नहीं है। जो भी सिक्योरिटी टूल्स
है, जैसे कि एसआईए हम अलग यूज़ कर रहे हैं,
ईडीआर अलग यूज़ कर रहे हैं। फायरवल का
रिलेटेड चीजें अलग यूज़ कर रहे हैं। ऐसा
कुछ नहीं करना है फॉर इन्वेस्टिगेशन। दे
कैन ऑपरेट ऑल दीज़ टूल्स विद इन अ सिंगल
सोर इंटरफ़ेस। ये सारे टूल्स को एक सिंगल
सो इंटरफ़ेस में ऑटोमेट किया जा सकता है और
सिंगल सो इंटरफ़ेस के अंदर यूज़ किया जा
सकता है। अलोंग विद यूनिफाइंग द
सिक्योरिटी टूल्स। सारे सिक्योरिटी टूल्स
को एक जगह लाने के साथ-साथ इट आल्सो
प्रोवाइड्स टिकटिंग एंड केस मैनेजमेंट
फीचर। ये टिकटिंग का भी फीचर प्रोवाइड
करता है। जैसे टिकट नाउ और वो सब जो
अलग-अलग टूल्स आते हैं टिकटिंग के सर्विस
नाउ या कुछ ऐसे करके आते हैं टिकटिंग के
टूल्स तो उन टूल्स को भी यहां इंटीग्रेट
किया गया है। तो मतलब सोर में सिक्योरिटी
है लॉगिंग का टिकटिंग का केस मैनेजमेंट का
सब एक साथ बना दिया गया और एक ऑल इन वन
प्लेटफार्म तैयार कर दिया गया। टूल तैयार
कर दिया गया जिसको सोर नाम दे दिया गया।
तो जितने इंटरप्राइज नेटवर्क हैं,
बड़े-बड़े कंपनीज़, नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर वहां सोर यूज़ होता है।
दैट्स इट। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है?
इट आल्सो प्रोवाइड्स टिकटिंग एंड केस
मैनेजमेंट फीचर्स टू द एनालिस्ट। ठीक है?
थ्रू व्हिच दे कैन डॉक्यूमेंट, ट्रैक एंड
रिज़ॉल्व देयर इंसिडेंट्स इन अ
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे। जिसके थ्रू वो अपने जो
भी इंसिडेंस है उनको डॉक्यूमेंट कर सकते
हैं, ट्रैक कर सकते हैं, रॉल्व कर सकते
हैं एक स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में। अब देखो सोर
जो है ये तीन तरह की
स्टेप्स पे डिपेंड करता है। सो के बेसिकली
तीन तीन स्टेप्स हैं जिसमें ये काम करता
है। एक ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन, दूसरा ऑटोमेशन और
तीसरा रिस्पांस। ये तीन तरह के स्टेप्स
में काम करता है। सो। अब ये तीनों
एग्जैक्टली किस तरीके से काम करते हैं वो
हम जानने वाले हैं। साथ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ही में हम
देखेंगे कि क्यों सोर जो है वो आपके लिए
इंपॉर्टेंट है। किस तरीके से सोर पहले के
ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी का जो ऑपरेशन हो रहा था
मैनुअल उसके लिए कितना ज्यादा बेटर यह एक
टूल है और किन-किन प्रॉब्लम्स को यह दूर
करता है वो भी हम जानेंगे। उन प्रॉब्लम्स
के बारे में बात करेंगे और क्या-क्या
प्रॉब्लम्स को दूर करता है। हम उसके बारे
में भी जानेंगे। ठीक है? बस बने रहिए साथ
में और फिर हम इसको एक हैंड्स ऑन के थ्रू
समझेंगे। लैब के थ्रू समझेंगे ताकि और भी
ज्यादा क्लेरिटी आपको मिल जाए। चलिए
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे आते
हैं। सबसे पहला स्टेप इसका जो सोर का होता
है सिक्योरिटी ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन का। इसको आप
बोल सकते हैं द कनेक्टर्स। इसको आप
कनेक्टर्स। ये ब्रैकेट में मैंने
कनेक्टर्स लिखा है ताकि आपके दिमाग में आप
इसको कनेक्ट कर पाए इस पर्टिकुलर स्टेप
को। सिक्योरिटी ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन यह बोलने और
समझने में बहुत टाइम लगता है और बहुत
ज्यादा कॉम्प्लेक्स लगता है। बट अगर आप
सोचेंगे कि यह कनेक्टर की तरह काम कर रहा
है तो आपको एग्जैक्टली याद रहेगा। कनेक्टर
का मतलब क्या है? ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन इज द
ग्लू। तो इससे आपको याद रखना है चीजों को।
ठीक है? अच्छा। अच्छा। सिक्योरिटी
ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन में कनेक्टर होता है ये।
इट्स अ कनेक्टर। अ सो ये ग्लू की तरह है।
हां। ठीक है। ग्लू है मान के चलो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इट इज द एबिलिटी टू कोऑर्डिनेट डिफरेंट
सिक्योरिटी टेक्नोलॉजीस जैसे एसआईएम,
मीडिया, फायरवॉल, आईएम टू वर्क टुगेदर
सीमलेसली। इसी का काम है कि जितने भी
अलग-अलग सिक्योरिटी टूल्स हैं उन सबको एक
साथ कनेक्ट कर देना ताकि वो सब एक साथ काम
करें। ये ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन है। इसमें दो
चीजें हैं। इंटीग्रेशंस एंड प्लगइन एप्स,
सोर प्लेटफॉर्म्स यूज़ प्रीबिल्ट
एप्लीकेशनेशंस और इंटीग्रेशन पैक्स। सो जो
है ना ये एक प्रीबिल्ड एप्लीकेशनेशंस यूज
करते हैं। ठीक है? या इंटीग्रेशन पैक्स
यूज करते हैं। जहां पे बेसिकली वो अ एपीआई
वगैरह के थ्रू भी काम करते हैं। जिस जो कि
सेकंड पॉइंट है मेरे एपीआई सेंट्रिसिटी।
इट रियलाइज़ हेवली ऑन रेस्ट एपीआईज़ व्हेन अ
सोर प्लेटफार्म वांट्स टू ब्लॉक एन आईपी।
इट सेंड्स एन एपीआई रिक्वेस्ट टू द फायर
वॉल जो कि इस तरीके का कुछ रिक्वेस्ट आपको
देखने को मिल सकती है। तो सोर का जो ये
प्लेटफार्म है सोर जो टूल है स्पेशली जब
सिक्योरिटी ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन की बात करते हैं
फर्स्ट स्टेप की तो ये बेसिकली एपीआई पे
काम करता है। ये एपीआई पे काफी ज्यादा
रिलाई करता है। एंड जब भी आप जैसे मान लो
कोई आईपी को ब्लॉक करना है। तो जनरली
मैनुअली क्या होता है कि उस आईपी को लिया
एसआईएम प्लेटफार्म एसआईएम टूल के अंदर
जाके मैनुअली आप उसको ब्लॉक कर दिया या
आपने कोई स्क्रिप्ट बना ली। अब सोर के
थ्रू वो सब चीजें कुछ नहीं। सोर को बस
आपको ब्लॉक करना है। सो को बोला कि भैया
ब्लॉक सोर अपना बैकग्राउंड में काम करेगा।
एक एपीआई रिक्वेस्ट भेज देगा फेरॉल को
भैया इस आईपी को इस ब्लॉक लिस्ट में डाल
दो। आईपी को ब्लॉक लिस्ट में डाल देना है।
सो यह काम ऑटोमेटिकली बैकग्राउंड में कर
देगा। एपीआई पे पूरा बेस्ड होता है और
आपको कुछ भी करने की जरूरत नहीं है। वो भी
सर्टेन रूल्स पे काम करता है कि कुछ इस
तरीके की अगर आईपीस हैं तो उनको ब्लॉक
लिस्ट में डालना है। कुछ इस तरीके की अगर
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है तो उनको ब्लॉक लिस्ट
में डालना है। ऐसी आ रही है तो ब्लॉक
लिस्ट में नहीं डालना है। तो दीज़ आर नोन
एज सम काइंड ऑफ ये एक ट्रिगर पॉइंट जो
होता है जिस पे चीजें ट्रिगर करेंगी वो
बनाई जाती है। बेसिकली इसको हम प्लेबुक के
थ्रू समझेंगे। ये जो तरीका है कि कैसे काम
करना है, क्या-क्या चीजें स्टेप लेनी है,
क्या-क्या करना है, ऐसा हो, तो वैसा हो,
यह यस हो तो वह हो, नो हो तो वह हो। यह जो
पूरा फंडा है, यह प्लेबुक्स के थ्रू
डिज़ाइन किया जाता है। और ये डिज़ाइन जो
प्लेबुक्स करती है, ये सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट्स यानी कि एसओसी एनालिस्ट ही
करते हैं। जो आप एज एसओसी एनालिस्ट होंगे
ना, तो आप ही प्लेबुक को डिज़ाइन करेंगे।
तो, एसओसी एनालिस्ट की तो जरूरत है ही।
तो, आप Playbook को डिज़ाइन करेंगे। भी मैं
बाद में बात करूंगा प्लेबुक के बारे में
तो उस पे और ज्यादा आपको क्लेरिटी मिलेगी
कि एक्सैक्टली क्या होता है। फिलहाल
ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन में क्या होता है? सारे
टूल्स को एक साथ इनका काम है लाके एक साथ
जग एक साथ काम करने के लिए एक जगह पे लाके
कनेक्ट करना। उसके बाद ऑप्शन जो सेकंड
स्टेप आता है सिक्योरिटी ऑटोमेशन का। ये
इसके ब्रेन होते हैं। ऑटोमेशन इज द ब्रेन।
सिक्योरिटी ऑटोमेशन। ऑटोमेशन इज द
एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ़ टास्क विदाउट ह्यूमन
इंटरवेंशन। सिंपल सा फंडा है कि ऑटोमेशन
का मतलब आपको भी पता है कि बिना हमारे
इंटरवेंशन के बिना ह्यूमन के इंटरेक्शन के
कोई टास्क हो रही है ऑटोमेटिकली ऑटोमेशन
है। तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वो
कैसे किया जाता है? वही जैसे मैंने अभी
बात की प्लेबुक्स या वर्क बुक्स के थ्रू।
ठीक है? वर्क सॉरी वर्क फ्लो के थ्रू।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
दीज़ आर स्टेप बाय स्टेप विजुअल फ्लो
चार्ट्स दैट डिक्टेट हाउ एन इंसिडेंट इज़
हैंडल। अब ये एक इंफोग्राफिक्स की तरह
होता है। जैसे आपने इंफोग्राफिक्स देखी
होगी। एक विजुअल फ्लो चार्ट होता है कि एक
इंसिडेंट को कैसे हायर कैसे हैंडल करना है
ऐसे होगा तो क्या होगा वैसे होगा तो क्या
होगा यस होगा तो क्या होगा नो होगा तो
क्या होगा ये हैंडलिंग का काम होता है
फ्लो वर्क फ्लोस में या प्लेबुक्स के थ्रू
दे कंटेन कंडीशनल लॉजिक इफ एल्स ट्रू यस
नो इस तरीके का इफ दिस मतलब तो ये ये ट्रू
हो गया एल्स दैट फॉल्स हो गया तो अगर ऐसा
होगा तो ऐसा अगर वैसा होगा तो वैसा तो ये
इस तरीके का इफ एल्स का स्टेटमेंट पे ये
काम करता है। एक प्लेबुक जो है वो तैयार
किया जाता है सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट्स के
द्वारा। ट्रिगर्स फिर यूज़ होते हैं एक्शंस
दैट किक ऑफ अ प्लेबुक। वहीं मैंने जो बोला
ट्रिगर पॉइंट कि एक ट्रिगर इफ अगर ऐसा हुआ
कि हां अगर इफ दिस एक्सटेंशन इज़ देयर देन
अह अह अह देन मार्क इट एज मलेशियस फाइल।
तो ऐसा हो सकता है। इफ डॉट exc इज देयर
मार्क इट एज मलेशियस फाइल। इफ डॉट एपीके
इज देयर मार्क इट एज मलेशियस फाइल। तो इस
तरीके से इफ एल्स में होता है और जहां
जहां पे वो ट्रिगर होता है वहां पे जो है
प्लेबुक जो है चलने लगता है और प्लेबुक के
अंदर उसी तरीके से काम होती है। ठीक है?
हां फ्लो चार्ट की तरह बिल्कुल सही बात
है। फ्लो चार्ट की तरह
वी कैन थिंक इट। अभी मैं दिखाऊंगा अभी आप
लोगों को लाइक आई विल शो यू आल्सो कि वो
किस तरीके का चार्ट होता है। सारी चीजें।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ठीक है? जिस
तरह जैसे एसआईएम अलर्ट फॉर फिशिंग रिसीप्ट
इस तरीके का। अब देखो अब लास्ट होता है
सिक्योरिटी रिस्पांस। तो पहला हमने देखा
है सिक्योरिटी ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन। दूसरा देखा
है सिक्योरिटी ऑटोमेशन। तीसरा देखा है
सिक्योरिटी रिस्पांस। अब मैं यहां पे
तीनों चीजें पहले यहां डील करूंगा। देन
मैं आपको ट्राईकमी पे भी आपको कुछ इसके
एग्जांपल दिखाऊंगा ताकि आपको और ज्यादा
शायद क्लेरिटी मिल जाए। अब सिक्योरिटी
रिस्पांस में द कॉन्टेक्स्ट एंड ग्राउंड
कंट्रोल इसको बोलते हैं। इसको हम द
कॉन्टेक्स्ट एंड ग्राउंड कंट्रोल बोलते
हैं। सो गिव्स द एबिलिटी टू टेक एकशंस
यूजिंग डिफरेंट टूल्स फ्रॉम वन यूनिफाइड
इंटरफ़ेस। एक इंटरफ़ेस वहां से सारे एकशंस
ले लो। सिंपल सा फंडा है। सो का मतलब यही
होता है भैया कि एक ही जगह से तुम सारे
काम एसओसी के कर पा रहे हो ऑटोमेटेड तरीके
से। दैट्स इट। यही है सोर। इट आल्सो
ऑटोमेट्स द रिस्पांस। रिस्पांस को भी ये
ऑटोमेट करता है। एज वी सॉ अर्लियर व्हाइल
लुकिंग एट इट्स ऑटोमेशन कैपेबिलिटी।
ऑटोमेशन करने के लिए ये बहुत ज्यादा
कैपेबल है। फॉर एग्जांपल सोर कैन फॉलो द
प्लेबुक ऑफ वीpए ब्रूड फ़ोर्स। स्लो जो सोर
है आपका यह एक वीpए ब्रूट फ़ोर्स का
प्लेबुक फॉलो कर सकता है। एंड ब्लॉक द
आईपीस ऑन द फायर वॉल। और फायर वाल पे
आईपीस को ब्लॉक कर सकता है। डिसेबल द यूजर
इन द आईएम। आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस
मैनेजमेंट के अंदर यूजर्स को डिसेबल कर
सकता है एंड ओपन अ टिकट विद ऑल द डिटेल्स
एंड एक टिकट भी ओपन कर सकता है ताकि उसमें
फर्दर प्रोसेसिंग हो सके कि ये सारी
डिटेल्स कि भैया देखो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स होने की
कोशिश की जा रही है हमारे इस आईपी पे जो
जहां पे हम वीpए जो है हमने सेटअप करके
रखा है वीpए सर्वर है और इन आईपीस को
ब्लॉक किया गया है farwal के तरफ से इन
यूज़र्स को डिसेबल किया गया है आईएम में तो
ये पूरा का पूरा टिकट एक ओपन कर देंगे और
उसमें सारी डिटेल्स मेंशन कर देंगे हमारे
एनालिस्ट के लिए यह काम हल्का कर देते
हैं। बेसिकली सोर का यूज़ एनालिस्ट के काम
को बहुत ही थोड़ा इजी थोड़ा बर्डन कम करने
के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है। बट ऑटोमेशन
बीइंग ऑटोमेशन टूल बीइंग टूल इट शुड बी इट
शुड बी मॉनिटर्ड बाय एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट
फॉर अ गुड आउटकम फॉर अ गुड ताकि कुछ
गड़बड़ी ना हो। तो एनालिस्ट को तो उसको
मॉनिटर करना ही पड़ता है। अब इसमें दो
चीजें हैं। थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस मैनेजमेंट और
आपका इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस केस मैनेजमेंट।
देखो मॉडर्न सोर प्लेटफॉर्म्स इंजेस्ट
थ्रेट फीड्स। जो अभी मॉडर्न जो भी सोर
प्लेटफॉर्म्स होते हैं वो थ्रेट फीड्स को
इंजेस्ट करते हैं। जो भी थ्रेट्स के आ रहे
हैं जो भी इनेशन आ रही है उसको इंजेस्ट
करते हैं। उसके अंदर में मतलब इंजेक्ट बोल
लो। इट ऑटोमेटिकली मैप्स इंटरनल अलर्ट
डेटा। अब ये क्या करता है? ऑटोमेटिकली
अलर्ट डेटा को मैप कर देता है अगेंस्ट दीज़
फीड्स। दीज़ ये जो फीड्स आ रहे हैं इसके
पास अलग-अलग लॉग्स जो आ रहे हैं उसके
अगेंस्ट जो है क्या करता है? ये अलर्ट
डेटा को मैप कर देता है टू इनरच द
इंसिडेंट कॉन्टेक्स्ट इमीडिएटली अपॉन
अराइवल। तो अब मान लो कोई मान लो कि अ कोई
एक अलर्ट आने वाली है मान लो। ठीक है? एक
अलर्ट आ रही है। अब कोई log है। log भी आ
गई। अब लॉग को जैसे जो भी लॉग इसके पास आ
रही है जो भी लॉग इसमें इंजेस्ट किए गए
हैं तो यह उन इंटरनल अलर्ट डेटा को
इन लॉग फीड पे मैप करता है।
अब जब मैप करेगा तो इंसिडेंट के बारे में
एग्जैक्टली हमें बहुत ही जल्द सब कुछ पता
चल जाएगा कि एग्जैक्टली किस तरह का ये
थ्रेट है। किस तरह का ये इंसिडेंट है।
क्या एग्जैक्टली पॉसिबिलिटीज हैं होने के?
यह सारी चीजें हमें तुरंत पता चल जाएगी।
यह इसका बेनिफिट है। तो थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
हम इसी को बोलते हैं कि थ्रेट के ऊपर में
इंटेलिजेंस करना जो भी थ्रेट जो पॉसिबल
थ्रेट्स हैं जो आपके सिस्टम को वनरेबल कर
सकते हैं, सिस्टम पे अटैक कर सकते हैं।
सिस्टम के वीकनेसेस को एक्सप्लइट कर सकते
हैं। तो ये उन थ्रेट्स के ऊपर इंटेलिजेंस
लगा के इंटेलिजेंटली काम करता है और उनको
अर्लियर या रियल टाइम में डिटेक्ट करने
में हेल्प करता है। दिस इज़ द पावर ऑफ़ सोर।
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस केस मैनेजमेंट। अब ये
क्या है? इफ ऑटोमेशन कांट फुल्ली रिॉल्व द
इशू। मान लो ऑटोमेशन पूरी तरीके से इशू को
रिॉल्व नहीं करता है। द इंसिडेंट बिकम्स अ
केस। तो अगर कोई ऐसा इंसिडेंट है जो पूरी
तरीके से रॉल्व नहीं हो पाता है। किसी भी
रीज़न से नहीं हुआ रहता है। तो वो एक केस
बन जाता है इन एसओसी। दिस कॉमोनेंट गिव्स
एनालिस्ट अ सेंट्रलाइज्ड डैशबोर्ड
कंटेनिंग द फुल ऑडिट ट्रेल ऑफ व्हाट द
ऑटोमेशन ऑलरेडी डड। अब ऑटोमेशन ने
एग्जैक्टली क्या-क्या किया है वो सारी
डिटेल्स एक सेंट्रलाइज़ डैशबोर्ड पे आपको
मिल जाएगी। उसके टाइमलाइंस एविडेंस लॉकर्स
फॉर फाइल्स एंड हैशेस मतलब एविडेंस के
अलग-अलग एविडेंसेस जो हैं फाइल्स के
डिटेल्स उनके हैशेस अलग-अलग चीजें एंड
कोलैबोरेशन टूल्स और जो टूल्स उनके साथ
काम कर रहे हैं। तो एव्री डिटेल्ड डिटेल
विल बी देयर इन अ सेंट्रलाइज्ड डैशबोर्ड।
एक डैशबोर्ड होगी उस पे सारी डिटेल जो है
दे दी जाएगी कि भैया आखिर यह जो पर्टिकुलर
इशू हुआ था इंसिडेंट हुआ था जो कि पूरी
रॉल्व नहीं हो पाई थी उस पे ऑटोमेशन के
थ्रू क्या-क्या चीजें हुई है। अब आगे
एसओसी एनालिस्ट अपना खुद ही देख लेगा। अभी
खुद ही देख लेगा भाई आगे क्या करना है?
मैनुअली देख लेगा जो चीजें वो कर लेगा। तो
वो सारी चीजें जो है आपको एक डैशबोर्ड पे
देखने को मिल जाती है सोर के थ्रू। यह है
पावर ऑफ़ सोर। यह मुझे लगता है समझ में
आपको आ गया होगा। अब हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ते
हैं। बट इसके पहले हम ट्राईकमी पर आके कुछ
चीजें आपको तीनों का दिखाऊंगा। तीनों का
मतलब ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन का, ऑटोमेशन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] का और रिस्पांस
का। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एग्जांपल के थ्रू थोड़ा सा एग्जांपल
दिखाऊंगा ताकि आपको थोड़ा इजी पड़ जाए।
देखो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे
ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन में क्या होता एग्जैक्टली
एग्जांपल के थ्रू थोड़ा समझ लेते हैं।
ठीक है?
ट्रेडिशनली क्या होता है? ट्रेडिशनली
एग्जैक्टली क्या होता है? व्हाइल
इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग एन अलर्ट एसओसी एनालिस्ट
हैज़ टू स्विच बिटवीन मल्टीपल सिक्योरिटी
टूल्स। ये जो नॉर्मली यही होता है फॉर द
एनालिसिस। ठीक है? फॉर एग्जांपल अगर कोई
वीपीए ब्रूट फ़ोर्स हुआ है तो एनालिस्ट
टिपिकली स्विचेस बिटवीन द फॉलोइंग टूल्स।
तो एनालिस्ट ये सारे टूल्स को यूज़ करेगा।
जनरली यही होगा। एक एसआईएम यूज़ करेगा।
किसके लिए? चेक करने के लिए कि यूजर
यूजुअली यूज अ सब्जेक्ट IP फॉर लॉगिन। वही
आईपी यूज़ हो कर रहा है। दूसरा थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफार्म यूज़ करेगा। दूसरा
क्या है? टीआई प्लेटफार्म। थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफार्म यूज़ करेगा आईपी के
रेपुटेशन को वेरीफाई करने के लिए। तीसरा
आईएएम टूल आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस मैनेजमेंट
टूल को यूज़ करेगा यूज़र्स को डिसेबल करने
के लिए। और चौथा टिकटिंग सिस्टम को यूज
करेगा। जैसे सर्विस नाउ हो या कोई भी
टिकटिंग सिस्टम जो भी यूज़ हो रही है टिकट
को ओपन करके ट्रैक करने का इंसिडेंट को ये
सारी चीजें करेगा। बट जब हम बात अब सोर की
करेंगे तो अब ये जो मैनुअली स्विच कर रहा
है टूल्स के बीच में अलग-अलग टूल्स के बीच
में। सोर के आते वो सब ऑटोमेट हो जाएगा।
अब सोर क्या करेगा? इट कनेक्ट्स डिफरेंट
टूल्स फ्रॉम वेरियस वेंडर्स विद इन द
यूनिफाइड सोर इंटरफ़ेस। अब सोर इंटरफेस के
अंदर सारे टूल्स को कनेक्ट कर दिया जाएगा।
इट डिफाइन वर्क फ्लोस फॉर इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग
वेरियस टाइप्स ऑफ़ अलॉट नोन एज़ प्लेबुक्स।
अब ये एक वर्क फ्लो बनाएगा कि ऐसा नहीं तो
ऐसा इफ नहीं तो इफ एल्स वाले फॉर्मेट में।
दीज़ प्लेबुक्स आर प्रीडफाइंड स्टेप्स दैट
टेल सोर हाउ टू इन्वेस्टिगेट अलर्ट। ये
प्लेबुक्स पहले से एक बनी बनाई जो हैं वह
स्टेप्स होते हैं जो सोर को बताते हैं कि
एग्ज़ैक्टली कैसे आपको काम करना है। अब सोर
के आने के बाद क्या होगा? देखो। फॉर
एग्जांपल वीपीए बूटफोर्स अलर्ट वी
डिस्कस्ड अबव वुड हैव द फॉलोइंग प्लेबुक
अब इस स्टोर में ये प्लेबुक होगा क्या
होगा देखो रिसीव्ड अलर्ट फ्रॉम एसआईएम
एसआईएम से अलॉट आया क्वेरी एसआईएम टू चेक
इफ द यूजर नॉर्मली यूजज़ द आईपी एसआईएम में
क्वेरी कर लेगा वो चेक थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
प्लेटफॉर्म्स फॉर आईपी रोटेशन सोर ही उसी
को चेक कर लेगा क्वेरी एसआईएम फॉर एनी
सक्सेसफुल लॉगिन सोर ही क्वेरी कर लेगा
एसआईएम को सक्सेसफुल लॉगिन के लिए और
एस्केलेट कर देगा कंटेनमेंट एक्शन के लिए
या रिपोर्टिंग के लिए आगे टिकटिंग सिस्टम
को एस्केलेट कर देगा। तो अब सोर ही एक ही
चीज सोर एक प्लेटफार्म एक टूल अब वो सारा
काम करेगा। एनालिस्ट को अब अलग-अलग टूल्स
के पास नहीं जाना। अलग-अलग टूल्स में
स्विच नहीं करना उसको। एक टूल सोर सारा
काम डन। सोचो एनालिस्ट का काम आसान हो
गया। पहले एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट को बहुत कुछ
करना पड़ता था यार। बहुत मुश्किल होती थी।
अब तो बहुत चीजें आ चुकी हैं। एडवांस
चीजें आ चुकी हैं। एंड इट्स क्वाइट इजी
फॉर देम। बस थोड़ा बैठे रहो। दिमाग अपनी
अपनी इंटेलिजेंस को चालू रखो और देखते
जाओ। डन टना कहां-कहां से क्या-क्या चीजें
आ रही हैं वो देखते जाओ। प्लेबक्स के
अकॉर्डिंग करते जाओ। दैट्स इट। खत्म। ये
बेनिफिट है। अब देखिए ये तो हो गया। अब
ऑटोमेशन के ऑटोमेशन पे आते हैं। द आर्ट ऑफ़
कोऑर्डिनेटिंग विथ मल्टीपल टूल्स थ्रू
प्रीडफाइंड एक्शंस प्लेबुक व्हिच वी
स्टडीड इन ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन कैन बी ऑटोमेटेड।
उसको ऑटोमेट किया जा सकता है। ऑटोमेशन
मींस नो मोर मैनुअल क्लिक्स। सही बात है।
कोई मैनुअल क्लिक्स नहीं होना चाहिए। ये
लिंक्स ये मैं सारे बंद कर देता हूं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
मैनुअल क्लिक्स नहीं होने चाहिए। एज से एज़
इट इज़। मतलब मैनुअल क्लिक्स नहीं होगा। सब
ऑटोमेटेड होगा। तो शोर क्या करता है?
प्लेबुक्स वाली चीजें फॉलो करता है। तो
क्या करता है? सोर रिसीव द अलर्ट फ्रॉम
एसआईएम। सोर को एसआईएम से अलर्ट मिलता है।
इट ऑटोमेटिकली रिक्वेरीज़ द एसआईएम फॉर
यूज़र्स हिस्टोरिकल लॉग इन। यह ऑटोमेटिकली
एसआईएम को क्वरी करता है यूज़र्स की लॉगिन
हिस्ट्री के लिए। इट ऑटोमेटिकली वेरीफाईज़
आईपी रेपुटेशन थ्रू थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
प्लेटफार्म। जैसे वायरस टोटल वगैरह ये सब
हो गए। तो थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफॉर्म से
ये ऑटोमेटिकली उसकी रेपुटेशन आईपी के
रेपुटेशन भैया कैसी आईपी किस तरह की आईपी
है देख लो उसको क्या करता है ये वेरीफाई
भी कर लेता है इफ द आईपी इज़ मलशियस अगर
आईपी मलिशियस है देखो इफ एल्स वाली आ गई
प्लेबुक में ऐसा ही होगा इफ एल्स इफ एल्स
अगर आईपी
मशियस हुआ तो इट ऑटोमेटिकली डिसेबल द यूजर
यह ऑटोमेटिकली डिसेबल कर देता है यूजर को
क्या करेगा एसोसिए एनालिस्ट क्या करेगा
मैं यह सोच रहा हूं बैठेगा देखेगा देखता
रहेगा लास्टली इट ऑटोमेटिकली ओपन्स अ टिकट
इन द टिकटिंग सिस्टम विथ ऑल द डिटेल्स टू
इनिशिएट एन इन्वेस्टिगेशन या एस्केलेशन यह
ऑटोमेटिकली टिकट ओपन कर देगा आगे के
इन्वेस्टिगेशन या L2 L3 के स्टेप्स के लिए
बस ये पूरी की कहानी ये पूरी स्टोरी ये
पूरी कहानी है इस तरीके से आपका भैया ये
काम करता है हमारा
सोर
दिस इज़ हाउ इट वर्क्स यह ऑटोमेशन है और
रिस्पांस में तो मैंने आपको बताया है
सिंपल सा सोर गिव्स द एबिलिटी टू टेक
एक्शन यूजिंग डिफरेंट टूल्स फ्रॉम वन
यूनिफाइड इंटरफ़ेस मतलब एक ही इंटरफ़ेस है।
वहां से आप रिसोंड कर सकते हैं। आल्सो ये
रिस्पांस को भी ऑटोमेट कर देता है।
जैसा मैंने बताया ना ये देख आप ये जो
स्टेप देख रहे हो तो रिस्पांस को ऑटोमेट
ही तो कर रहा है। दिस इज़ द ऑटोमेशन ऑफ़
रिस्पांस। तो ये पूरा आपका हमारे सोर भैया
जो हैं वो करते हैं। बट यहां पे भी हो
सकता है आप में से कई लोगों को शायद बहुत
कुछ क्लियर ना हुआ हो। तो उसको और भी
क्लियर करेंगे। वह हम करेंगे चैलेंजेस को
देखते हुए कि ट्रेडिशनल एसोसिएट चैलेंजेस
क्या है और सोर कैसे उसको ठीक करता है।
इससे और भी ज्यादा आपको क्लेरिटी मिल
जाएगी।
लाइफ के बीच में ऐड हां ऐड तो लाइफ के बीच
में आ ही जाती है भाई। उसको तो क्या ही कर
सकते हैं। चलो अब ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी चैलेंज
क्या है? जैसे ट्रेडिशनल वे मतलब नॉर्मली
कैसे जैसे एसोसिए चैलेंजज़ को यूज़ करते
हैं। अब यहां पे सोर के साथ क्या पंगा है?
देखो इन अ ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी एसओसी
एनालिस्ट्स आर ऑफेन फाइटिंग द
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर रेदर देन द एडवर्सरीज
ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी ऑपरेशन में एसओसी
एनवायरमेंट में जो हमारे
एनालिस्ट भाई साहब हैं वो
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चरल
सेटअप इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चरल कॉन्फ़िगरेशन से ही
तंग आ जाते हैं परेशान हो जाते हैं।
अटैक्स थ्रेट से तो बाद में लड़ेंगे।
उन्हीं से परेशान है बेचारे वो।
ठीक है? हां, जरूरत होगी। अभी लेट आए
होंगे। मैंने बता दिया है। वैसे क्यों
जरूरत होगी? मैं फिर रिपीट कर दूंगा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
तो इशूज़ क्या-क्या हैं? पहले वो देखते
हैं। सबसे पहला इशू है अलर्ट फैटिक एंड द
नीडल इन अ हेयर स्टक। अलर्ट फैटिक एंड द
नीडल इन द हेयर स्टक। नीडल इन द हैशक का
मतलब है कि मान के चल लो कि भूसे में एक
भूसा होता है ना भूसा भूसा जो एक तरह का
चारा होता है गाय भैंस वगैरह को खिलाए
जाते हैं गांव में जो गांव से होंगे या
गांव से ताल्लुक रखते होंगे या तो उनको
इसका आईडिया होगा भूसा तो भूसा जो होता है
वो गाय बछड़े भैंस को खिलाया जाता है वो
बहुत ही हल्का होता है और बहुत ही बड़े से
स्टक में रखा रहता है। उसके अंदर एक नीडल
गिरा दो तो उसको खोज नहीं पाओगे। वो ऐसा
हो जाएगा कि समंदर में नीडल गिरा दो और
उसको वहां से खोजो।
है ना? या सरसों के दाने को गिनो। कुछ इस
तरीके से। तो अब ये उसी तरीके की कंडीशन
हो जाती है। ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी में। क्या
है? चैलेंज क्या है? अ ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी
क्या दिक्कत क्या आती है? पहले वो देखते
हैं। फिर उसका हम सॉल्यूशन देखेंगे। अ
ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी इंजेस्ट मिलियंस ऑफ लॉग्स
डेली फ्रॉम एसआईएम्स, ईडीआर, फायर वाल्स,
वीपीएंस मिलियंस ऑफ़ लॉ्स को वो इंजेक्ट
करता है। दिस क्रिएट्स अ मैसिव वॉल्यूम ऑफ़
अलर्ट्स। अब इसके कारण इतने ज्यादा
अलर्ट्स आते हैं। इतने ज्यादा अलर्ट्स आते
हैं जिसका कोई लिमिट नहीं है। उसी को हम
अलर्ट फैटिक बोलते हैं। और हाई परसेंटेज
ऑफ़ व्हिच आर फॉल्स पॉजिटिव। उसमें से भी
बहुत सारे अलर्ट जो होते हैं वो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स होते हैं।
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स होते हैं। अब मान लो 1000
अलर्ट्स आ रहे हैं और उसमें से पता चले
800 अलर्ट्स 800 जो अलर्ट्स हैं वो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है। कितना बुरा लगेगा? अगर ये
चीजें मॉनिटर करनी पड़े, फिल्टर करनी पड़े
एक एनालिस्ट को उसकी तो बैंड बज जाएगी
भाई। वो सोचेगा जॉब कर रहा हूं कि ये फ़्टर
वाली काम कर रहा हूं। फिल्टरेशन कर रहा
हूं।
एनालिस्ट स्पेंड आवर्स क्लिकिंग थ्रू द
रिपीिटेटिव अलर्ट्स लीडिंग टू बर्न आउट
एंड वर्स मिस्ड क्रिटिकल इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ़
कॉम्प्रोमाइज। और इस चक्कर में एनालिस्ट
बेचारा बर्न आउट फील करता है। टेंशन में आ
जाता है। और जो इंपॉर्टेंट आईओसी होते
हैं, इंपॉर्टेंट जो एक्चुअल थ्रेट्स को
इंडिकेट करते हैं, उसको कई बार मिस भी कर
देता है। यह तो चैलेंज हो गया। सिंपल। यह
चैलेंज हो गया। अब इसका सॉल्यूशन सोर लेकर
आता है हमारा सोर। कैसे? क्या करेगा भाई?
सोर एक्ट एज अ हाई स्पीड फ़िल्टर। सोर
ऑटोमेटिकली एक फिल्टर की तरह भी काम करता
है। सो सब कुछ है। सो
यूनिवर्सल
थर है थर। इट इंजेस्ट दीज़ अलर्ट्स
एंड रंस देम थ्रू ऑटोमेटेड प्लेबुक्स टू
डी डुप्लीकेट कोरिलेट एंड फिल्टर आउट नोन
बिनग नॉइज़
मतलब कि यह क्या करता है? यह सारे अलर्ट्स
को लेता है। उनको एक ऑटोमेटेड प्लेबुक के
अगेंस्ट रन कर देता है। प्लेबुक में वही
एक फ्लो चार्ट बनी होती है कि इफ ऐसा तो
ऐसा एल्स ऐसा तो वो एक कंडीशन बेस्ड फ्लो
चार्ट बनी रहती है इफ एल्स वाली। अब उसमें
डाल दिया सारे अलर्ट्स को कि अगर ऐसा
अलर्ट होगा तो इसको गोली मारो। अगर ऐसा
अलर्ट होगा तो ही इसको अप्रूव करो। इसको
ट्रू पॉजिटिव रखो।
और फिर जितने भी फालतू की चीजें हैं
डुप्लीकेट्स हैं उनको हटा देता है। सारी
चीजें फ़िल्टर आउट कर देता है। जितने नॉइज़
और गार्बेज डाटा है उनको अलर्ट से उनको
गायब कर देता है। दैट्स इट।
यह काम करता है मरसोर। एनालिस्ट्स ओनली सी
हाई फेडेलिटी
प्रीवेटेड इंसिडेंट्स दैट एक्चुअली
रिक्वायर ह्यूमन इंटशंस। हाई फेडेलिटी का
मतलब होता है हाई फिडेलिटी का मतलब होता
है हाई
ट्रस्ट वाले या हाई आप उस पे ये सोच सकते
हो कि यह जो है हाईली सेंसिटिव है या
ज्यादा रिलेटेबल है।
ऐसी जो अलर्ट्स होते हैं वही फिर
एनालिस्ट्स देखते हैं जो लगता है कि हां
सबसे ज़्यादा पॉसिबल या नियर टू दैट
पर्टिकुलर अटैक हो कि हां भाई ये सही है
इसको हम अस्यूम कर सकते हैं कि हां भैया
ये अलर्ट सही है। तो एनालिस्ट इसके कारण
सोर के कारण अब फालतू की सारी चीजें नहीं
देखता है। वो कुछ सिलेक्टेड हाई फेडिलिटी
यानी कि ज्यादा ट्रस्टेड जो अलर्ट्स हैं
जिस पे ज्यादा भरोसा किया जा सकता है।
ज्यादा ट्रू अलर्ट्स जो है फिर उसको वह
देखना शुरू कर देता है जिसमें एक्चुअल
ह्यूमन इंटरवेंशन चाहिए होता है। ऐसा नहीं
कि बस टाइम वेस्ट कर रहा हो। तो पहला तो
प्रॉब्लम यह था जिसका सॉल्यूशन हमारा सोर
देके गया। ठीक है? हां, सोर इज द गॉड ऑफ़
एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट्स। बिल्कुल सही बात है।
सो प्लेटफार्म को भी आप यूज़ करेंगे। जब आप
किसी कंपनी में, बड़े कंपनी में जाते हैं,
तो दे मस्ट बी हैविंग दीज़ टूल्स। अब दूसरे
प्रॉब्लम्स के बारे में बात करते हैं। टूल
डिस्परेट फ्रेगमेंटेशन
इसको हम द स्वीवेल चेयर इफेक्ट बोलते हैं
या स्वेल चेयर इफेक्ट प्रोनंसिएशन जो भी
कर लो। क्या होता है इसमें? चैलेंज क्या
आता है? दिक्कत क्या आती है? टू
इन्वेस्टिगेट अ सिंगल सस्िशियस ईमेल। एन
एनालिस्ट हैज़ टू ओपन एन ईमेल गेटवे कंसोल।
एक सिंगल अगर सस्िशियस ईमेल है तो
एनालिस्ट को पूरा का पूरा ईमेल गेटवे
कंसोल को ओपन करना होता है। थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस पोर्टल एक थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
पोर्टल को ओपन करना होता है। जैसे वायरस
पोर्टल हो गया। एन एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी
पोर्टल टू चेक यूजर एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी
पोर्टल को यूज़ को ओपन करना पड़ता है।
यूज़र्स यूज़र्स को चेक करने के लिए एंड एन
ईडीआर कंसोल टू चेक द एंड पॉइंट। और एंड
पॉइंट्स के ऊपर क्या हुआ है उसको चेक करने
के लिए ईडीआर कंसोल को ओपन करना होता है।
दिस कॉनस्टेंट कॉन्टेक्स्ट स्विचिंग स्लोस
डाउन द रिस्पांस टाइम। और जब ये चीजें
होती हैं तो प्रॉब्लम आना शुरू होता है कि
रिस्पांस टाइम कम हो जाता है। रिस्पांस
टाइम जो है वो थोड़ा सा स्लो हो जाता है।
सो यहां पे आया और सोर क्या इसका सशन लेकर
आया? सोर प्रोवाइड्स ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन जैसा
हमने पहले पढ़ा। इट कनेक्ट्स ऑल दीज़
डिस्पैरेट टूल्स वाया एपीआई। अब ये सारे
टूल्स को एपीआई के थ्रू कनेक्ट कर देता
है। सो एपीआई
ये आपको पता होगा एपीआई के बारे में कि एक
जगह से कोई इंफॉर्मेशन दूसरे जगह अगर लेके
जाना हो फच करवाना हो तो एपीआई का यूज़
किया जाता है एप्लीकेशन प्रोग्रामिंग
इंटरफसेस का। फुल फॉर्म है कि एपीआई जैसे
आप मोबाइल पे वेदर देखते हो वेदर। मोबाइल
का आप खोलते हो वेदर एप्लीकेशन पे जाके
अपना सिटी डालते हो। सिटी डालते ही आपको
उस सिटी की वेदर दिख जाती है। तो बेसिकली
क्या होता है वो जो एप्लीकेशन है वो वेदर
एपीआई को कांटेक्ट करती है और वहां से उस
सिटी की वेदर के रिपोर्ट आपके सामने ला के
रख देती है और आपके पास रिपोर्ट आ जाती
है। सेम एपीआई काम करते हैं। यहां की
इनेशन वहां पे रिमोटली कहीं और प्रोवाइड
करना। सो प्रोवाइड्स ऑर्केटिंग। अब यहां
पे इंटू अ सिंगल पेन ऑफ़ ग्लास। ये सारे
टूल्स को एक एपीआई के थ्रू एक ही जगह पे
कनेक्ट कर देता है। एंड एनालिस्ट डज़ नॉट
लीव द सोर प्लेटफार्म। एनालिस्ट सोर
प्लेटफार्म को लीव नहीं करता है। द
प्लेटफार्म रीचेस आउट टू द टूल्स ऑन देयर
बिहाफ। एनालिस्ट के बिहाफ में सोर
प्लेटफार्म ही सारे टूल्स तक रीच करता है।
मतलब इसका देखो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसका एक सिंपल सा एग्जांपल देता हूं। सो
क्या है? जैसे अब मैं एक कंपनी चला रहा
हूं। ठीक है? मान लो तो स्टार्टिंग फेज
में मैं जब कंपनी चला रहा था मान लो तो
मैं ही सारे काम कर रहा था। ठीक है? मैं
ही अ मार्केटिंग का भी काम कर रहा था। मैं
ही कंटेंट का काम कर रहा था। मैं ही
ट्रेनिंग का काम कर रहा था। मैं ही अ
लाइक
तुम्हारा ऑफलाइन कोई काम था उसका कर वो
चीजें कर रहा था। शेड्यूलिंग का काम मैं
ही कर रहा था। सारा काम मैं ही कर रहा था।
अब जब धीरे-धीरे कंपनी बड़ी हुई, जब
कॉम्प्लेक्स कंडीशन आनी शुरू हुई, तो अब
एक ऐसे बंदे को हमने रख लिया जो मेरे
बिहाफ पे बाकी सारे काम कर रहा है।
मार्केटिंग का भी काम देख ले रहा है। मतलब
मॉनिटर कर ले रहा है। इधर हम कंटेंट का भी
काम मॉनिटर कर ले रहा है। हर एक काम को
मॉनिटर कर ले रहा है। तो सोर वही है। सो
बेसिकली एनालिस्ट के लिए एनालिस्ट का सबसे
बड़ा हथियार है। जो ऑटोमेशन के लिए,
रिस्पांस के लिए, ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन एक जगह
सारे टूल्स को कनेक्ट करने के लिए यूज़ में
लिया जाता है। मतलब सोर का काम बस इतना है
एनालिस्ट के लिए कि सारे टूल्स को भैया एक
जगह कनेक्ट कनेक्ट कर दो सबको एक दूसरे के
साथ एपीआई के थ्रू। उसके बाद जो भी
प्रोसेससेस है उसको ऑटोमेट कर दो और
ऑटोमेटेड रिस्पांस प्रोवाइड कर दो।
रिस्पांस दे दो। जो भी थ्रेट आने वाली है
या अलर्ट आ रहा है। दैट्स इट।
दिस इज ऑल सोर। समझ में आ गया होगा। आई
थिंक सोर आपको इतना क्लियर पहले कभी नहीं
हुआ होगा जो आज आपको क्लियर हो गया होगा।
तो ये थी दूसरी प्रॉब्लम। एक और प्रॉब्लम
है स्लग इज़ मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट एंड
रिसोंड एमटीटी एमटीटीआर। इसके बारे में
मैंने ऑलरेडी प्रीवियस क्लासेस में आपको
एमटीटीडी मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट मीन टाइम टू
रिस्पांस बताया हुआ है। पढ़ाया हुआ है। आप
जब पिछले क्लासेस अगर आपने देखे होंगे तो
आपको पता होगा नहीं देखे होंगे। जब आप
देखेंगे तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। फिलहाल
हम एमटीडीीडी और एमटीटीआर पे नहीं जा रहे
हैं। उसका कोई अभी फिलहाल मतलब नहीं है।
जो भी होगा आपको यहां पे बता दूंगा मैं।
इसमें प्रॉब्लम क्या आ रही है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इसमें इशूज़
क्या रहे हैं? मैनुअल ट्रैग टेक्स टाइम।
जो मैनुअल ट्रैग होती है उसमें टाइम लगता
है। कॉपी पेस्टिंग आईपीस इनू lookअप
टूल्स। अब सारे आईपीस को कॉपी करो। lookअप
टूल में डालो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओपनिंग टिकट्स मैनुअली मैनुअली टिकट को
ओपन करो। एंड वेटिंग फॉर ईमेल कंफर्मेशन
फ्रॉम यूज़र्स। और यूजर्स का ईमेल
कंफर्मेशन का वेट करो कि भैया हां भैया
हां हां हां यही चीज हुई थी। हां यही है।
कैन स्ट्रेच एन इंसिडेंट्स लाइफ साइकिल
फ्रॉम मिनट्स टू डेज। और यही चीजें एक
जो इंसिडेंट होती है उसकी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लाइफ साइकिल
को जो कि बहुत शॉर्ट होनी चाहिए कि तुरंत
भाई अभी कोई इंसिडेंट हुई और तुरंत उसके
रेमेडी हो गया। तुरंत वो उसको सही कर दिया
गया। उसको मतलब रिजॉल्व कर दिया गया। तो
वह कम होना चाहिए टाइम।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो वो टाइम यहां पर क्या होता है? वो टाइम
यहां पर बढ़ा दी जाती है। चैलेंज ये आया कि
वो भाई मिनट्स में ना होके डेज में होती
है। ऐसी मैनुअली चीजें हो रही हैं। तो सोर
हमारा क्या करता है? अब ऑटोमेशन
एग्जीक्यूट्स रेपिटेटिव टास्क्स एट मशीन
स्पीड। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ऑटोमेशन
इनहीं रेपिटेटिव टास्क को मशीन की स्पीड
से करती है। व्हाट टूक एन एनालिस्ट 45
मिनट्स ऑफ मैनुअल क्लिकिंग
इज कंप्लीटेड बाय अ सोर प्लेबुक इन लेस
देन 5 सेकंड्स ड्रास्टिकली ड्रॉपिंग द
एमटीटीआर और मीन टाइम टू रिस्पांस को यह
45 मिनट से 5 सेकंड पे लेकर आ गया। यह एक
इस तरीके का प्लेटफार्म है। सब कुछ ऑटोमेट
करके यह जो सारी मैनुअली चीजें हो रही थी
उसको ऑटोमेटिकली किया जा रहा है। ऑटोमेटेड
किया जा रहा है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] और जो 45 40
45 मिनट लग रहे थे अब 510 सेकंड में वो
काम हो जा रहा है। सोचो अ ह्यूज गैप इन
एमटीटीआर मीन टाइम टू रिस्पांस। मतलब एक
रिस्पांस करने में कितना टाइम लगता है?
कितना बड़ा गैप हो गया।
दिस इज़ द ब्यूटी ऑफ़ सोर। दैट्स व्हाई यू
शुड बी लर्निंग। यू शुड बी नोइंग अबाउट
सोर। [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
बहुत सारे आपको एसओसी के कोर्स में सोर
आपको नहीं मिलेगा जानने को। एसओसी एल1 के
लिए सोर आपको पढ़ाएंगे भी नहीं। बहुत सारी
क्लासेस में। याद रखिएगा। सोर आपको नहीं
पढ़ाया जाएगा। एसओसी क्लासेस के लिए बहुत
सारे ऐसे कोर्सेज हैं जहां पे सोर के बारे
में नहीं बताया जाएगा। मैं आपको बता रहा
हूं। इसका रीज़न है कि मैं आपको वन स्टेप
अहेड रखना चाहता हूं। एक स्टेप थोड़ा
फॉरवर्ड रखना चाहता हूं। जब आप इंटरव्यू
वगैरह देने जा रहे हैं। इंटरव्यू वगैरह
मान लो इंटरव्यू में आपसे नहीं भी पूछता
है कुछ। बट अगर आप वर्क करने जा रहे हैं
वहां पे जब वर्किंग स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं तो
आपको इसका बेनिफिट इन सब चीजों का
बेनिफिट्स आपको समझ में आ जाएगा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] क्योंकि आपको
बाकी जो टीममेट्स होंगे उनसे ज्यादा नॉलेज
होगी। प्रैक्टिकली भी, डेमोंस्ट्रेटिकली
भी और कॉनसेप्चुअली भी जो सबसे ज्यादा
जरूरी है। और कहीं इंटरव्यूअर थोड़ा दिमाग
से सटका हुआ निकला। थोड़ा सोचेगा कि अरे
इनके मजे लेते हैं। थोड़ा घुमा के पूछेगा
आपसे कुछ एक्स्ट्रा पूछ दिया तो आप
एक्स्ट्रा वो कवर कर पाएंगे। ये एक्स्ट्रा
चीजें कवर मैं ऑलरेडी धीरे-धीरे आपको
कराता चल रहा हूं। तो उसकी टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है आपको। तो ये तीसरा प्रॉब्लम था
जिसका हमारा सॉल्यूशन सो हमारे भाई साहब
देते हैं। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब इन दोनों
में एक कंपैरिजन देख लेते हैं ताकि और भी
एक फ्रेश आपको
कंपैरिजन मिल जाए और फ्रेश आपको समझ में आ
जाए एक्सैक्टली कि क्या किस तरीके से ये
होते हैं काम करते हैं। तो फीचर्स हम पहले
देखेंगे। देन ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी में
क्या-क्या होते हैं और सोर इनेबल्ड एसओसी
जो एसओसी ऑपरेशन हो रहे हैं जिसमें सोर
इनेबल्ड एसओसी है तो ओनली एसआईएम बेस नहीं
है तो उनमें क्या डिफरेंस है?
ठीक है? यह देखते हैं। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] पहले ट्रैक
टाइम का बात करते हैं। तो ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी
सेटअप में मिनट्स टू आवर्स लग जाते हैं।
मैनुअल होता है लुकअप बट सोर इनेबल्ड में
ये सेकंड्स में होता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ऑटोमेटेड
होता है। प्लेबुक एग्जीक्यूशन की बात करें
तो ये रिटेन इन पीडीएफ डॉक्यूमेंट्स। ये
स्टैटिक होता है।
स्टैटिक होता है। इसको क्या करते हैं? यह
पीडीएफ वगैरह टाइप डॉक्यूमेंट्स में लिखा
होता है। बट स्टोर इनेबल्ड एसोसिएट
एनवायरमेंट में क्या हो जाता है?
एग्जीक्यूटेड वाया कोड या वर्क फ्लो। यह
वर्क फ्लो के थ्रू या प्लेबुक के थ्रू
इसको एग्जीक्यूट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] किया जाता है
और ये डायनेमिक होता है। इसको चेंज किए जा
सकते हैं अपने रिक्वायरमेंट के अकॉर्डिंग।
ह्यूमन रोल की बात करें तो डाटा गैदर
एंड बटन क्लिककर। डाटा को गैदर करना और
बटन को क्लिक करना यह ट्रेडिशनल एसओसी
एनवायरमेंट में ह्यूमंस करते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सोर में क्या
होता है? हाई लेवल डिसीजन मेकर एंड थ्रेट
हंटर। सोर में ह्यूमंस की रिक्वायरमेंट
वहीं पे होती है जहां पे कोई हाई लेवल
डिसीजन मेकिंग करनी होती है। क थोड़ी
लॉजिकल डिसीजन मेकिंग करनी होती है। जो
टूल्स या मशीनंस नहीं कर पाएंगी। जनरली
नॉट एटलीस्ट एआई तो नहीं कर सकती हैं।
अंटिल एजीआई इज़ देयर। तो अभी तक तो कुछ
ऐसा नहीं होता है। तो वहां ह्यूमन
इंटरवेंशन इज़ वेरीेंट। एंड द
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लास्ट इज़ टूल
इकोसिस्टम।
तो यहां पे सिलोइड डिस्कनेक्टेड कंसोल्स
एंड यहां पे ऑर्केस्ट्रेटेड यूनिफाइड
एपीआई इमेज। इसका मतलब यहां पे है कि ये
एक तरह का डिस्कनेक्टेड कंसोल्स अन
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड कंसोल टाइप का होता है कि
भाई आप अलग-अलग खोलो कंसोल्स को फिर उसमें
अलग-अलग टूल्स पे काम करो। और इसमें क्या
होता है? सारे एक दूसरे से कनेक्टेड होते
हैं एपीआई के थ्रू और सब जो है ऑटोमेटिक
तरीके से काम करते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? इफ सोर कैन डू एवरीथिंग देन व्हाई
अ
टूल्स लाइक एस या एसआईएम और ईडीआर स्टिल
एक्सिस्ट। यही देखो ये कांसेप्ट आपको
क्लियर रहना चाहिए। मैंने कई बार इस चीज
को बताया। हालांकि मैं एक बार फिर से
रिपीट कर देता हूं। शायद और लोगों को कहीं
अगर इसके क्वेश्चन हो। आप शायद रेगुलर
नहीं होंगे हर क्लासेस में। अदरवाइज मैंने
ये चीजें पहले बताई थी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कि सोर है
इसका मतलब एसआईएम की जरूरत ना हो। यह
किसने बोला और कैसे यह पॉसिबल है? एसआईएम
ही कांसेप्ट है। एसआईएम ही तो टूल है वो
प्लेटफार्म है। सो बस एक तरीका आपको दे
रहा है।
समझ में आ रहा है? सो एक तरीका दे रहा है।
काम आपका एसआईएम ही सब कर रहा है। सो इज अ
प्लेटफार्म टू
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ऑटोमेट
थिंग्स।
चीजों को ऑटोमेट कर रहा है।
यह तो वही बात हो गई कि हम कोड लिख रहे
हैं। उसको स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू ऑटोमेशन करते
हैं। तो अरे यार स्क्रिप्ट तो है ही तो
कोड लिखने की क्या जरूरत है? अरे भैया कोड
लिखोगे तभी तो स्क्रिप्ट्स ऑटोमेट करोगे।
तो सेम थिंग अप्लाई हियर। आई थिंक योर
क्वेश्चन जो था उसका आंसर आपको मिल गया
होगा और क्लियर भी हो गई होंगी। तो पहले
जो इनिशिएट कर चीजें जिससे हो रही हैं वो
तो होनी ही चाहिए। तभी तो उसके ऊपर तुम
मल्टीपल लेयर्स या चीजें अप्लाई करोगे ना।
राइट? आई [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
थिंक इट्स क्लियर नाउ। राइट? क्लियर है?
सही है। चलिए अच्छी बात है। तो ये
कंफ्यूजन बहुत लोगों को हो सकता है। तो
मैंने इसको क्लियर थोड़ा कर दिया है। ठीक
है? तो जब तक कोड नहीं लिखोगे और
स्क्रिप्ट कैसे बनाओगे? तो जब तक एक्चुअल
एक्शन नहीं लोगे उसको ऑटोमेट कैसे करोगे?
है ना? एक्शन तो लिया जा रहा है ना टूल्स
ईडीआर और एसआईएम जैसे टूल्स के द्वारा
उसको बस ऑटोमेट करना है और एक
ऑर्केस्ट्रेट करना है। दैट्स इट। कनेक्ट
करना है टूल्स को। सारे उन्हीं टूल्स को
तो कनेक्ट किया जा रहा है। अब टूल्स ही
नहीं रहेंगे तो कनेक्ट कैसे करोगे? कैसे
होगा? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] राइट?
दिस इज अ थिंग।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] ओके।
उसके बाद अब हम आते हैं यहां पे प्लेबुक
के ऊपर में। ये प्लेबुक के ऊपर में आता
है। अब ये प्लेबुक क्या है? पहले उसको
थोड़ा सा समझते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देन हम इस पे आते हैं। देखो
देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम यहां पर एक फिशिंग प्ले बुक का
एग्जांपल लेंगे। क्या
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] है ये बताता
हूं मैं। फिशिंग अटैक्स रिमेंस द मोस्ट
कॉमन अटैक वेक्टर यूज्ड इन ब्रचेस। फिशिंग
अटैक एक ऐसा चाहे वो स्पेयर फिश किसी भी
तरह का स्पेयर फिशिंग हो या किसी भी तरह
का फिशिंग हो। फिशिंग अटैक सबसे ज्यादा
यूज़ में लिया जाता है टू अटैक ऑन
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। फिशिंग हो गया।
उसके थ्रू फिर रैंसमवेयर अटैक करवा दो,
मैलवेयर अटैक करवा दो, कुछ भी करवा दो। बट
फिशिंग के थ्रू ही मोस्टली सारी चीजें
होती है। ठीक है? सबसे सब सबसे ज्यादा
अनफॉर्चूनेटली
फॉर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग
फिशिंग ईमेल्स बिकम टाइम कंज्यूमिंग एंड
इनवॉल्व्स मैनुअल एक्सरसाइजज़ सच एज
एनालिंग एनालाइजिंग अटैचमेंट्स, यूआरएल्स,
वेरीाइंग थ्रू थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
प्लेटफॉर्म्स। ये सब मैनुअली करना पड़
जाता है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
दिक्कत यही है। व्हाइल अदर इन्वेस्टिगेशंस
आर ऑनगोइंग सोर सॉलशंस कैन एग्जीक्यूट दीज़
टास्क इन द बैकग्राउंड वाया प्लेबुक। अब
सोर जो है इसी फिशिंग को फिशिंग
इन्वेस्टिगेशन को प्लेबुक के थ्रू ऑटोमेट
कर सकते हैं। ऑटोमेशन हो सकता है। एंड
इसका रेमडेशन, इसका सॉल्यूशन, इसको रिॉल्व
किया जा सकता है। जब कोई फिशिंग ईमेल कहीं
पर आती है तो
इस तरीके से। तो अब यह कैसे प्लेबुक काम
करता है? कुछ इस तरीके का यह प्लेबुक होता
है। देखो किस तरीके से यहां पे है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] स्टार्ट हुआ
यहां पे। इस प्ले इस इसको भी मैं समझाता
हूं। फिर मैंने जो आपके लिए लाया है
प्लेबुक रखा है उसको भी मैं समझाऊंगा। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जैसे एक
सिंपल सा प्लेबुक को समझो। यहां पे एक
सिंपल सा फिशिंग प्लेबुक है। कुछ इसी
तरीके से एक फ्लो चार्ट बनती है। स्टार्ट
करते हैं। सस्पेक्टेड ईमेल रिसीव्ड। कोई
एक सस्पेक्टेड ईमेल रिसीव हुआ है किसी
यूजर को कंपनी के अंदर में। ठीक है? अब ये
जो ईमेल है कंटेंस यूआरएल ऑफ अटैचमेंट्स।
क्या ये अटैचमेंट्स का यूआरएल कंटेन करते
हैं? नो। तो अगर ऐसा नहीं है तो नोटिफाई
यूजर ओवर स्टक चैनल्स और यही यह स्टेप
खत्म हो जाता है। लेकिन अगर
यस होता है तो अब यह पूछा जाएगा कि क्या
अटैचमेंट कंटेन करते हैं या सिर्फ
यूआरएल्स कंटेन करते हैं। तो अगर सिर्फ
अटैचमेंट कंटेंस करते हैं तो उसके अंदर उस
उसकी हैश को कंप्यूट किया जाता है। अगर
यूआरएल कंटेन करते हैं तो यूआरएल को थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफार्म जैसे वायरस टोटल पे
भेज दिया जाता है एनालिसिस
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
के लिए। फिर जो अटैचमेंट हुई होती है जो
हैश कैलकुलेट हुआ तो अब कंप्यूट हैश टू
वायरस टोटल अब वो हैश को कंप्यूट करके और
वायरस टोटल पे चेक किया जाता है कि ये हैश
मलशियस है कि नहीं है इस फाइल का ये हैश
एक्चुअल में मलिशियस हैश है या नॉन मलशियस
है और जब ये अगर हैश मैलिशियस होगा
तो फिर क्या होगा मैनुअल एनालिसिस ऑफ ईमेल
इन अ सैंड बॉक्स फिर ईमेल का मैनुअल
एनालिसिस स्टार्ट होता है सैंड बॉक्स
एनवायरमेंट में एक सेपरेट एनवायरमेंट में
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] और अगर नो
होगा तो फिर यूआरएल का जो ऑप्शन है यूआरएल
मलशियस है तो नो तो फिर मैनुअल एनालिस
मलेशियस नहीं है तो भी फिर कोई बात नहीं
एनालिसिस मैनुअल का क्योंकि यहां पे फाइल
का मलशियस आया हुआ है तो मैनुअल एनालिसिस
होगा अगर यूआरएल मलेशियस है तो ईमेल
डिटेक्ट हुई और इसको फिर जो है इसका टिकट
क्रिएट कर दिया जाता है इन क्रिएट
इन्वेस्टिगेशन टिकट और उस पे फर्दर
ऑपरेशंस जो है वह प्रोसेससेस जो होते हैं
और यहां पे अगर यह जो अटैचमेंट है इसका
फिर मैनुअल एनालिसिस होता है। मलिशियस अगर
है तो क्या किया जाता है? अगर यूआरएल हो
मलेशियस या अटैचमेंट हो तो ईमेल को जो है
डिलीट कर दो। भाई ये ईमेल हटा दो। ईमेल को
डिलीट मारो और इसका एक इन्वेस्टिगेशन टिकट
टिकट रेज कर दो। टिकट क्रिएट कर दो। उसमें
सारी डिटेल्स लिख दो कि भैया ऐसी-ऐसी
चीजें हुई है। ऐसी-ऐसी प्रॉब्लम्स हुई
हैं। देख लो इस तरीके की चीजें हुई है। तो
ये इस तरीके का वर्क फ्लो होता है या
प्लेबुक्स होते हैं जो बनाए जाते हैं कि
अगर यूआरएल भी मलिश है तो ईमेल डिलीट मारो
या मलिशस फाइल भी उसके अंदर ईमेल डिलीट
मारो। ईमेल को डिलीट मारना इसलिए जरूरी है
क्योंकि अगर ईमेल रहेगा बाय चांस कभी किसी
ने फाइल पे क्लिक कर दिया। इनफेक्ट कर
दिया अपने एक सिस्टम को और उससे पूरी
सिस्टम लैटरली मूवमेंट फिर करने लगा हैकर।
नेटवर्क में फैल गया। सारी चीज़ होने लगी।
तो इट विल बी अ प्रॉब्लमेटिक थिंग।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इस तरीके से
यह काम करता है। अब मेरे पास भी एक इसका
प्लेबुक है। थोड़ा सा डिफरेंट है। उसको भी
हम देखते हैं। अ फिशिंग रिस्पांस
जस्ट अ सेकंड। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
फिशिंग रिस्पांस सोर प्लेबुक है ये आपका।
तो इसमें मैंने यहां पे पांच स्टेप्स मैं
आपको बताए हैं। पहला है ट्रिगर एंड इंजेशन
का। दूसरा है इनरचमेंट
ट्राई स्टेज। तीसरा है एनालिसिस कोरिलेशन
स्टेज। चौथा है रिस्पांस मिटिगेशन स्टेज।
पांचवा है पोस्ट इंसिडेंट एंड
रिस्पॉन्डिंग या मतलब रिपोर्टिंग स्टेज।
पहले में ट्र ट्रिगर इंजेशन में क्या होता
है? एसएमएस या ईमेल वाली जो अलर्ट होती है
वो आती है आपकी। यूजर रिपोर्टिंग यूजर
रिपोर्ट करते हैं भैया ऐसा ईमेल या कुछ
एसएमएस आया कुछ ऐसा। प्लेबुक एक्टिवेट हो
जाता है जो प्लेबुक बनी है अपना भैया और
अलर्ट डाटा पासिंग होती है। जैसे कि यूजर
यूआरएल हो गया, सेंडर आईपी हो गई,
रिसिपिएंट हो गया, अटैचमेंट हैज़ हो गया।
ये सारे उसके डिटेल्स जो है निकाले जाते
हैं उस पर्टिकुलर ईमेल के थ्रू। अब यहां
से फिर क्या जाता है? थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस के
पास भेजा जाता है डिटेल्स निकाल के जैसे
कि वायरस टोटल या साइबर इंट ऐसे
प्लेटफॉर्म्स हैं उनको निकाला जाता। अब
यहां पे यूआरएल या आईपी का रेपुटेशन चेक
किया जाता है कि भैया किस रेपुटेशन के ये
मलेशियस यूआरएल या आईपी है या नॉन मलेशियस
है। फिर एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी को खंगाला जाता
है कि यूजर प्रोफाइल के बारे में पता किया
जाता है। किस टाइप का यूजर जो है टारगेट
किया जा रहा है। कोई हाई लेवल यूजर है लो
लेवल मिड लेवल यूजर है उसको उसके बारे में
पता किया जाता है। देन ईडीआर के पास जाता
है। एंड पॉइंट पोश्चर चेक कि भैया एंड
पॉइंट जो हमारी लैपटॉप मॉनिटर या हमारा
डिवाइस कोई नेटवर्क डिवाइस है उस पे कितना
इंपैक्ट डाल रहा है यह। उस पर कितना
इंपैक्ट यह डाल सकता है उसको चेक किया
जाता है। अब यहां पे पूछा जाता है कि इज द
अलर्ट हाई फेडिलिटी? क्या यह ज्यादा
प्रॉब्लमेटिक अलर्ट? मतलब ज्यादा भरोसेमंद
अलर्ट है कि हां भैया ये ज्यादा चांसेस
कितने हैं कि ये अलर्ट सच में एक्चुअली
में मलेशियस है। तो अगर यस हाई फेडिलिटी
वाली होगी यस तो फिर आगे के स्टेप्स में
जाएंगे। नो तो यहीं पे फॉल्स पॉजिटिव बोल
के इसको डिसमिस कर दिया जाएगा।
तो जब अगर हाई फिडिलिटी की होगी तो जाते
हैं फिर एनालिसिस या कोरिलेशन स्टेप्स पे।
तो यहां पर क्या होगा? कोरिलेट आईओसीस
अक्रॉस द नेटवर्क। जितने भी इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइजज़ हैं उनसे कोरिलेट किया जाता
है। इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज जो बने
होते हैं जो मैंने पहले बताए हुए हैं आपको
पिछले क्लासेस में। उनसे मैच किया जाता
है। देखा जाता है कि भाई किससे ये कौन से
इंडिकेटर से मैच कर रहा है। एनालाइज़
अटैचमेंट इन द सेट बॉक्स। और जो फाइल या
अटैचमेंट होती है उसको अलग एक सेपरेट
एनवायरमेंट में अटैचमेंट को एनालाइज किया
जाता है। चेक पास्ट इंसिडेंट हिस्ट्री और
फिर पास्ट के हिस्ट्री को देखा जाता है कि
भैया पास्ट में भी कुछ इस तरीके का कोई
अटैचमेंट या यूआरएल कुछ सामना हुआ है
क्या? ठीक है? कुछ पाला पड़ा है क्या
हमसे? वो चेक किया जाता है। ठीक है? और
अगर पाया जाता है कि मलेशियस है तो फिर
आगे की तरफ प्रोसेस होती है। नहीं तो यहीं
पे को केस को क्लोज कर दिया जाता है। अब
यहां पे अगर यह मलेशियस पाया जाता है देन
यहां पे नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे आते हैं
रिस्पांस एंड मिटिगेशन पे। ठीक है? फिर
यहां पे क्या होता है? पूरा ऑटो ट्रैकिंग
इसकी की जाती है। जो भी यूआरएल है उनको
फायरवल पर ब्लॉक कर दिया जाता है। इडीआर
पॉलिसीज को अपडेट किया जाता है। उन
पर्टिकुलर टाइप ऑफ फायर यूआरएल्स और
फाइल्स के लिए। यूजर के पासवर्ड को रिसेट
कर दिया जाता है। ठीक है? और सेमी ऑटो
ट्रैक में यहां पे रिव्यू यहां पे मिलता
है। बेसिकली रिव्यू करना होता है। ह्यूमंस
यहां पे ह्यूमंस की इंटरवेंशन जरूरी है इस
स्टेप में। तो एसोसिए एनालिस्ट इस पूरे
रिक्वेस्ट को रिव्यू करता है। ठीक है? और
इसके मिटिगेशन स्टेप्स को एग्जीक्यूट करता
है। तो मिटिगेशन स्टेप्स क्या है?
एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट इसके अ मिटिगेशन
स्टेप्स क्या होता है? एसोसिए एनालिस्ट के
द्वारा जब ये इसको एग्जीक्यूट करता है तो
डिलीट ईमेल एंटरप्राइज वाइड। ईमेल को
एंटरप्राइज वाइड डिलीट कर देता है। ईमेल
को भैया ईमेल को ही पूरी ईमेल को पूरे
एंटरप्राइज नेटवर्क से डिलीट कर देता है।
सारे सिस्टम को जो जितने भी सिस्टम है
पहले पता लगाएगा सबसे डिलीट मारेगा और उस
होस्ट को आइसोलेट कर देता है ईडीआर के
थ्रू। ईडीआर आइसोलेशन का काम कर का फीचर
देती है। होस्ट को आइसोलेट कर सकती है तो
उसको आइसोलेट कर देता है। ठीक है? ये
चीजें होती है। अब ये जब एग्जीक्यूशन हो
जाती है मिटिगेशन स्टेप्स की मतलब डिलीट
वलीट हो जाती है ईमेल। उसके बाद अगला
स्टेप आता है पोस्ट इंसिडेंट और
रिपोर्टिंग वाली स्टेप जिसमें कि टिकट
सिस्टम जैसे सर्विस ना हो उसको यूज़ किया
जाता है। टिकट बनाया जाता है। टिकट क्रिएट
किया जाता है। इंसिडेंट का पूरा रिपोर्ट
एक तैयार किया जाता है। एंड थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस रिपोर्ट एक बनाई जाती है।
जिसमें थ्रेट्स के बारे में सारी डिटेल्स,
सारे स्टेप्स, सारे जो भी
मेजर्स लिए गए वो सारी डिटेल्स वहां पे
होती है। सारी चीजें मेंशन की जाती है। एक
रिपोर्ट तैयार किया जाता है। आगे फर्दर
एस्केलेट किया जाता है या आगे फ़दर फ़ॉरवर्ड
किया जाता है और केस को क्लज़ या तो केस को
वहीं पे क्लज़ कर दिया जाता है। अगर आगे
फॉरवर्ड नहीं हो रही है एस्केलेट नहीं हो
रही है तो केस को वहीं पे क्लोज कर दिया
जाता है कि भैया ठीक है अब सब कुछ हो गया
है भैया हमने स्टेप ले लिया है केस को
क्लोज कर देते हैं। फर्दर कोई ऐसी
इन्वेस्टिगेशन की जरूरत इसमें नहीं है।
पता चल गया कि ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव नहीं थी।
ट्रू पॉजिटिव थी। ईमेलवल डिलीट हो गई सब।
एंड यहां पे हमारा ये जो थ्रेट है कंट्रोल
में आ चुका है। इस तरीके से पूरा का पूरा
ये काम करता है। इस तरीके के ये एक फिशिंग
प्लेबुक थी। इसी तरीके से हर अटैक का एक
प्लेबुक बनता है। हर अटैक का एक प्लेबुक
क्रिएट होता है। एंड यही प्लेबुक का सीन
यहां पे ट्राईकमी के अंदर में
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सीवी पैचिंग का
भी एक प्लेबुक दिया हुआ है। जो सीवी कॉमन
वबिलिटीज एंड एक्सपोज़र होता है जो कि
वनेबिलिटीज को पब्लिकली डिस्क्लोज़ करके और
उसको एक असाइन किया जाता है सीवी नंबर
उसके बारे में है। तो वो भी ये पूरा स्टेप
है। अब ये स्टेप भी बहुत लंबा चौड़ा स्टेप
है। अगर आप इसको देखेंगे तो आप यहां पे
आके बेसिकली देख सकते हैं। तो ये इस तरीके
से एक सीवी वो भी किया जाता है। अह
एक प्लेबुक बनाया जाता है। प्लेबुक कुछ
इसी तरीके से काम करती है। आपको आई होप कि
प्लेबुक का कांसेप्ट समझ में आ गया होगा।
एक फ्लो चार्ट के थ्रू ऐसा होगा तो वैसा
करना है। फिर ये होना है। फिर वो होना है।
ऐसे करना है, वैसे करना है। इफ एल्स वाले
स्टेटमेंट के साथ। सो इज इट क्लियर टू
एवरीबडी? प्लीज लेट मी नो।
सॉरी ब्रदर इंग्लिश में तो क्लासेस नहीं
हो पाएंगी। [हंसी] हमारे चैनल पे हिंदी
में ही क्लासेस होती है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो आपको अगर ये क्लासेस देखनी है तो आपको
हिंदी में ही देखनी पड़ेगी। मतलब या तो
सीखना पड़ेगा।
क्लियर है? एवरीथिंग क्लियर? एवरी एवरीबडी
शुड रिसोंड। मुझे रिस्पांस सबका नहीं मिल
रहा। प्लीज रिस्पांस कीजिए सभी लोग।
आई एम वेटिंग फॉर एवरीबडीज़ रिस्पांस।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सर थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस इसमें कवर करेंगे कि
नहीं? करेंगे क्या? देखो
एसओसी एनालिस्ट के लिए जो चीजें जरूरत है
एल1 के लिए वो सब कवर होंगी। बस सिंपल सा
फंडा है। अगर एल1 के लिए वो जरूरत नहीं है
तो वो कवर नहीं होगी। जरूरत होगी तो कवर
हो जाएगी। बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहिए। क्लियर
है? चलिए तो आज के लिए स्लाइड में तो बस
इतना ही था। स्लाइड में और कुछ भी नहीं
है। लेकिन
क्लास में है। तो अभी देखिए ट्राईमी के
ऊपर मैं आता हूं। अब यहां पर ट्राईकमी के
ऊपर में यह सारी चीजें मैंने आपको बता दी
जो यहां पे इन्होंने बताया हुआ है।
बेसिकली ये इन्होंने अपने तरीके से बताया।
मैंने आपको अपने तरीके से बताया है। ठीक
है? अब यहां पे इनका एक लैब है थ्रेट
इंटेल वर्क फ्लो प्रैक्टिकल। इसको थोड़ा
हम करके ट्राई करते हैं। ये इसमें शायद
आपको थोड़ा सा मजा आएगा। ठीक है? थोड़ा सा
मजा आएगा। तो यहां पे सिनेरियो क्या है?
यू [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आर पार्ट ऑफ
एसओसी टीम। आप एसोसिएट टीम के पार्ट हैं।
दैट रिसेंटली फेस्ड अ लार्ज डाटा ब्रीच
इन्वेस्टिगेशन दैट ड्रैग्ड ऑन फॉर एजेस
ड्यू टू लैक ऑफ ऑटोमेशन। अब ऑटोमेशन के
कारण लैक ऑफ ऑटोमेशन के कारण डेटा ब्रीच
बहुत टाइम से जो हुआ है तो उसका
इन्वेस्टिगेशन चल ही रहा है। ऐसे ही पड़े
हुए हैं। योर फ्रेंड मैक्सिडे रिसेंटली
एडवाइज्ड अडॉप्टिंग अ सोर एंड सेटिंग अप
ऑटोमेशन वर्क फ्लो। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आप मेरा एक
फ्रेंड है [हंसी] एक मैक्स किडी उसने
एडवाइस किया कि भाई सोर यूज़ कर लो। मैंने
बोला अच्छा यह बात है क्या? टू हेल्प योर
सिक्योरिटी इन्वेस्टिगेशन मेरे सिक्योरिटी
इन्वेस्टिगेशन के लिए। एम स्किडी या
मैक्सिडी सेंट यू अ चेक लिस्ट फॉर अ थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस इंटीग्रेशन वर्क फ्लो एंड योर
टास्क इज़ टू फिगर आउट हाउ इट वर्क्स। अब
इसने मैक्सिडी ने बोला कि इतना आसानी से
तुम्हें नहीं दूंगा सब प्री प्री
प्रिपयर्ड। तुम्हें मैं क्या कर रहा हूं?
चेक लिस्ट भेज रहा हूं। तुम अपने से उन
चेक लिस्ट को फिगर आउट करो कि कैसे कौन सा
चीज काम करेगा। कौन सी चीज ऑटोमेटेड स्टेप
होगी। कौन सी चीज मैनुअल स्टेप हो सकती
है। ये हमें फिगर आउट करना है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? इन दिस सिनेरियो योर जॉब इज़ टू
डिटरमाइन एंड सेट व्हिच पार्ट ऑफ द वर्क
फ्लो। वर्क फ्लो का कौन सा पार्ट मैनुअल
होना चाहिए और कौन सा पार्ट ऑटोमेटेड होना
चाहिए। यह इस लैब का पार्ट है। यह
प्रीमियम लैब है। याद रखिए गाइज़। एंड दिस
इज नाउ पार्ट ऑफ द ट्राईकमी मैक्स
सब्सक्रिप्शन। ट्राईकमी का एक अलग नाटक चल
रहा है। चल रहा है। अब पहले तो प्रीमियम
सब्सक्रिप्शन थी। आप लोगों को मिल जा रही
थी और सस्ती भी थी काफी ₹400 ₹500 पर मंथ
इंडियन अगर बात करें तो अब इन्होंने ये
मैक्स सब्सक्रिप्शन ला दिया है जो कि 2027
जून के बाद से एक्टिवेट हो जाएगी। तो जो
भी मैक्स वाले टॉपिक्स हैं वो प्रीमियम
वाले यूजर से एक्सेस नहीं कर पाएंगे। उनको
मैक्स में अपग्रेड करना पड़ेगा 27 जून 27
जून 2027 के बाद से अभी तो कर पाएंगे अगर
कोई प्रीमियम है तो मैक्स वाले में भी कर
पाएंगे बट उसके बाद वो नहीं कर पाएंगे अब
इन्होंने मैक्स का चार्ज कुछ ज्यादा रख
दिया है शायद $1-19 पर मंथ तो मुझे लगता
है कुछ ज्यादा ही है शायद तो ये सोचे कि
चलो भाई अब थोड़ा और पैसा बना लेते हैं
बढ़िया से हालांकि दिस इज़ नॉट गुड स्टेप
यह गुड स्टेप नहीं है आई थिंक ट्राई हैक
मी के बहुत सारे जो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] है वो
यूजर्स
इसको शायद छोड़ दे इसके कारण। आई डोंट नो
आई डोंट नो अबाउट बट आई थिंक थोड़ा सा
रिस्पांस तो कम होगा। तो यह मैक्स का
पार्ट है। तो मैं इसको अगर आपको दिखा रहा
हूं तो प्लीज आप इसको देखिए। गो थ्रू इट।
तो यहां पे अब करना क्या है भैया? कि आपको
मैनुअल और ऑटोमेटेड सेट करना है। तो व्यू
साइट पे चलते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यह यार ज़ूम क्यों नहीं हो रहा है? लेट्स
प्रोसीड पे करते हैं। ठीक है? कुछ इस
तरीके का इंटरफ़ेस आपको दिख रहा दिख रहा
होगा। राइट? [खांसने की आवाज़] यह इधर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसको बड़ा करने वाला ऑप्शन क्यों नहीं आ
रहा है यार?
कभी-कभी नहीं आता ये भी अलग ही तरीके का
फंडा है ये। हां, नहीं आ रहा है ये।
स्ट्रेच करने वाली वो आ ही नहीं रही है
इधर। चलो इतने में ही देख लेते हैं। कोई
बात नहीं है।
प्रो पे तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
नहीं है डेस्कटॉप का नहीं है क्या Galaxy
का
20 पिक्सल 7 ओके
नहीं है इसका
चलो इसको तो इधर करने का कुछ नहीं है। चलो
कोई बात नहीं है। चलिए अब यहां पे आते
हैं। यहां पे टास्क क्या है? देखो
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एडजस्ट द सेटिंग्स फॉर ऑटोमेटेड एंड
मैनुअल फ्लोस टू अडॉप्ट अ सोर एंड सेट अप
ऑटोमेशन वर्क फ्लो। दैट विल हेल्प यू इन
योर सिक्योरिटी इन्वेस्टिगेशंस। तो यहां
पे एक फ्लैग आएगी। वह फ्लैग डालना है
भैया। और यह फ्लैग तभी आएगी जब आप
करेक्टली सारे प्रोसेस को सेटअप करेंगे।
तो एक-एक [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
करके हम समझते हैं। पहले है कोर्स ऑफ
एक्शन देन रेपुटेशन चेक देन डेटा
एक्सट्रैक्शन देन थ्रेट इंटेल एंड देन
क्रिएट टिकट। तो कोर्स ऑफ़ एक्शन में चलते
हैं। अब यहां पे एक दो तीन चार पांच चीजें
हैं। तो मुझे आप लोग बताइए पहला, दूसरा,
तीसरा, चौथा, पांचवा जो भी है या पहला,
दूसरा, तीसरा, चौथा, पांचवा व्हाटएवर।
इसमें कौन सा ऑटोमेटेड होगा, कौन सा
मैनुअल होगा? ये स्विच पे क्लिक करके आपको
बताना है। तो पहला है ब्लॉक डोमेनस। तो
डोमेनस को ऑटोमेटिकली ब्लॉक कर सकते हैं।
ये तो ऑटोमेटेड होगा। राइट? सभी लोग आंसर
करते जाइएगा तुरंत-तुरंत। उसके बाद है
ब्लॉक आईपीस। इसको भी हम ऑटोमेटेड रख सकते
हैं। ओके? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
उसके बाद है ब्लॉक यूआरएल्स। तो या वी कैन
डू इट ऑटोमेटेड। अपडेट केस टिकट्स। अब केस
के टिकट को अपडेट करना है। ठीक है? तो
इसको मैनुअल अभी रहने देते हैं। एनालिस्ट
अप्रूव सीओए कंफर्मेशन ऑफ एक्शंस एंड
रिमडेशन। यह एनालिस्ट जो है अप्रूव करेगा।
तो इसको भी मैनुअल रहने देते हैं फिलहाल
के लिए। ओके कर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देते हैं। अब
आते हैं दूसरे पे
रेपुटेशन चेकक्स पे। तो पहले हम इसी को रन
करके देख लेते हैं। फिलहाल तो अच्छा हमने
तो सारा किया ही नहीं। पहले सबको कर लेते
हैं। रेपुटेशन चेक्स पे आते हैं। इसमें
आते हैं रेपुटेशन रिजल्ट्स आउटपुट। कंपाइल
रिजल्ट्स फ्रॉम वायरस टोटल। इसको ऑटोमेट
किया जा सकता है। सैंडबॉक्स टेस्टिंग
इंटीग्रेट यूजिंग प्लेटफार्म सच ऐज़ एनी
रन। इसको भी ऑटोमेट किया जा सकता है। एंड
एनालिस्ट वैलिडेशन सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट का
वैलिडेशन करना ये तो मैनुअली ही रहेगा।
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट खुद मैनुअली करेगा।
डेटा इंस्ट्रक्शन पे आते हैं। एक्सट्रैक्ट
डोमेनस ऑटोमेट हो सकता है। एक्सट्रैक्ट
यूआरएल ऑटोमेट हो सकता है। एक्सट्रैक्ट
आईपीस ऑटोमेट हो सकता है। एनालिस्ट
एक्सट्रैक्शंस। एनालिस्ट कोई एक्सट्रैक्ट
करेगा तो मैनुअली ही रहने देते हैं। थ्रेट
इंटेल में आते हैं। फेच न्यू इंसिडेंट
अलर्ट्स। तो इसको भी ऑटोमेट किया जा सकता
है। सेट फच इंटरवल्स इसको भी ऑटोमेट कर
सकते हैं। फेल्ड फच नोटिफिकेशन इसको भी
ऑटोमेट कर सकते हैं। डिस्कार्ड ओल्ड
अलर्ट्स जो ओल्ड अलर्ट्स हैं उनको
डिस्कार्ड कर देना। अब ओल्ड अलर्ट्स को भी
हम ऑटोमेट तो कर ही सकते हैं। फिलहाल हम
अभी कर देते हैं। बाद में देखेंगे कि सही
है कि नहीं है। उसके बाद आता है लास्ट में
केस मैनेजमेंट। तो क्रिएट केस टिकट। यह
मैनुअल रहने देते हैं। असाइन केस टिकट
असाइनमेंट भी देखो टिकट क्रिएट करना
वी कैन डू ऑटोमेटेड या असाइन केस टिकट
करना ये आप ऑटोमेटेड रहने देते इसको मैं
ऑटोमेटेड करते हैं। इसको मैनुअल छोड़ देते
हैं। कम अ कम्युनिकेट केस टिकट कम्युनिकेट
ऑटोमेट करते हैं। अपडेट ऑटोमेट करते हैं।
डिलीट द केस टिकट एपीआई यूज्ड फॉर डिलीशन।
ये भी ऑटोमेट कर देते हैं। तो ये सारी
चीजें हमने कर ली है। यहां पे कम्युनिकेट
क्या है? है इंटीग्रेशन चैनल सच ऐज़ ईमेल
स्लैक यह भी ऑटोमेट कर सकते हैं। एंड केस
मैनेजमेंट असाइनमेंट यह असाइन एक मैनुअल
हम रहने देते हैं। तो इस तरीके की हमने
सारी चीजें कर ली है। अगर हमारी सारी
स्टेप सही होंगी तो हमें फ्लैग मिल जाएगा।
अदरवाइज ये हमें बताएगा कि कहां पे कुछ
गड़बड़ी होने की चांसेस हैं। तो हम यहां
पे रन पे क्लिक करेंगे। एंड लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग। क्लिक ऑन रन। लेट्स सी
अह
गड़बड़ है। गड़बड़ क्या है? केस टिकट
सेटिंग में गड़बड़ है। तो केस टिकट सेटिंग
में क्या गड़बड़ हो सकती है? उसको हम एक
बार देख लेते हैं। देखो
केस टिकट क्रिएट करना यूज़ सर्विसेस सच एज
सर्विस नाउ द हाई ये
ऑटोमेटेड है हमारा। ठीक है? असाइन केस
टिकट। ठीक है? इसको हम ऑटोमेटेड कर देते
हैं। और
इसको तो ऑटो केस टिकट को क्रिएट करने को
हम मैनुअल रखते हैं। ठीक है? एंड बाकी
चीजें ऑटोमेट हमारी रखते हैं। टिकट जो
क्रिएट होगी वो मैनुअली होगी और फिर इसको
रन करके देखते हैं कि सेम एरर इसमें एरर
है अब या नहीं है। तो अभी भी एरर है। तो
क्रिस टिकट पे चलते हैं। नाउ व्हाट देयर
शुड बी एरर? तो यहां पे हम क्या कर सकते
हैं? देखो केस क्रिएट करते हैं।
एपीआई यूज़्ड फॉर डिलीशन। हां, इसको हम
मैनुअल कर देते हैं। इसको हम इसको भी
मैनुअल कर देते हैं। डिलीट केस करने वाले
को कि केस जो डिलीट होगी वह मैनुअली होगी।
अब रन पे क्लिक करके देखते हैं। लेट्स सी
अभी भी इशू है। इसको हम ऑटोमेट इसको
ऑटोमेट कर देते हैं। क्रिएट केस मैनुअल
में डिलीट करने का एक ऑप्शन रखते हैं और
फिर इसको रन करते हैं। लेट्स सी इफ इट इज़
करेक्ट। हां, बिल्कुल सही है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बिल्कुल सही
है। हमारा केस टिकट बिल्कुल सही है। इसलिए
हमें केस टिकट में इशू नहीं है। मतलब कोई
भी एरर नहीं आई है। हमने केस टिकट को
क्रिएट करना ऑटोमेटर रखा है। हमने असाइन
करना ऑटोमेटर रखा है। कम्युनिकेट करना
ऑटोमेटर रखा है। अपडेट करना ऑटोमेटिक। बट
डिलीट वाला हमने मैनुअली रखा है कि भ
मैनुअली डिलीट करेंगे। दैट्स इट। अब यहां
पे इशू आ रही है थ्रेट Intel में। आई थिंक
लेट्स सी अगेन। थ्रेट Intel में। थ्रेट
Intel में क्या है भैया? न्यू इंसिडेंट
अलर्ट्स। फेच करेगा ऑटोमेटिकली। बिल्कुल
सही बात है। सेट फेच इंटरवल्स ये भी सही
है। फेल्ड फेच नोटिफिकेशन।
तो ये भी सही है। और डिस्कार्ड हां
डिस्कार्ड को हम मैनुअल कर देते हैं
क्योंकि डिस्कार्ड जो करेंगे अ डिलीट करने
वाले वो हम मैनुअली ही डिलीट करेंगे
ज्यादा बेटर होगा। तो हम रन पे क्लिक करते
हैं। देखते हैं अब थ्रेट वाला सही है कि
नहीं हमारा।
हां ये अब बिल्कुल सही है। अब एक इशू आई
है हमारे रेपुटेशन चेकक्स में। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हमने पहले कर
लिया सारा कुछ। अब हम चेक कर रहे हैं कि
रेपुटेशन में क्या है? एक्सट्रैक्ट डोमेनस
ऑटोमेटेड ही होगा। एक्सट्रैक्ट यूआरएल्स
ऑटोमेटेड है। एक्सट्रैक्ट आईपीस ऑटोमेटेड
है। एक्स एनालिस्ट एक्सट्रैक्शन एनालिस्ट
डाटा एक्सट्रैक्शन फॉर नोन अननोन या न्यू
थ्रेट lookups अननोन और न्यू थ्रेट
lookups तो इसको भी ऑटोमेटेड ही कर देते
हैं। और क्या ऑटोमेटेड कर देते हैं इसको
भी रेपेटेशन में भी। इसको भी ऑटोमेट सारे
ऑटोमेटेड रहते हैं रेपेटेशन में।
फिर डेटा
नहीं नहीं सॉरी सॉरी डेटा एक्सट्रैक्शन
में इट वाज़ गुड ना एक्सट्रैक्ट डोमेनस
रिट्रीव डोमेनस डेटा फॉर नोन थ्रेट लुकअप
ऑन वायरस टोटल ओके
ओके
रिट्री यूआरएल डेटा फॉर नोन थ्रेट लुक अप
ऑन अच्छा अच्छा अच्छा ओके ओके देखो देखो
देखो यूआरएल डाटा रिट्रीव करना वायरस टोटल
से आईपी डाटा वायरस टोटल से एनालिस्ट
एक्सट्रैक्शन जो है वो चीजें तो अभी एक
सेकंड रुक जाइए मैं एक चीज स्टार्ट कर
देता हूं जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस इसको हम देखते
हैं दो मिनट बस दे दीजिए मुझे
मैं एक क्लास को थोड़ा सा वो कर दूं
यूआरएल डेट रिट्रीव करना वायरस से आईपी
डाटा वायरस से एनालिस
ओके चलिए हां हो गया। हां। तो अब इसमें हम
क्या-क्या स्टेप्स लेंगे पहले वो देखते
हैं। ठीक है? एक सेकंड रुक जाइए। हम
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एनालिस्ट एक्सट्रैक्शन को मैनुअल करते
हैं। ये हमने पहले भी करा था। अ बट लेट्स
सी डेटा एक्सट्रैक्शन में क्या होता है।
अब
हां डेटा इंस्ट्रक्शन सही है ये। अब
रेपुटेशन चेक्स पे आते हैं। रेपुटेशन
चेक्स पे आते हैं। ये डेटा एक्सट्रैक्शन
सही है हमारा। इसमें एरर नहीं आया। ये
सारे ऑटोमेटेड है। पहले भी यही था यार।
फिर क्या दिक्कत आई थी पता नहीं। अच्छा
मैनुअल इसमें आ भी नहीं रहा था शायद इशू।
एनालिस्ट एक्सेशन मैनुअल था। ठीक है? सही
है। अब [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
रेपुटेशन चेक्स में एरर आई है। क्या आई है
भाई? रेपुटेशन रिजल्ट्स आउटपुट कंपाइल
रिजल्ट्स फ्रॉम वायरस टोटल ऑटोमेटिक हुआ।
इंटीग्रेट यूजिंग प्लेटफार्म सच एनी सैंड
बॉक्स टेस्टिंग ऑटोमेटेड है। एनालिस्ट्स
वैलिडेशन एनालिस्ट एनालिसिस ऑफ़ रिजल्ट्स
एंड कंफर्मेशन ऑफ़ केस। ये तो मैनुअली
होगा। तो सही है ना रेपुटेशन? क्या दिक्कत
है? रेपुटेशन दूसरा भी होगा क्या? सैंड
बॉक्स वाला भी मैनुअल होगा क्या? अच्छा ये
भी मैनुअल होगा। सैंड बॉक्स टेस्टिंग भी
यहां मैनुअल करने को शायद ये चाहता है कि
हम मैनुअल करें क्योंकि सैंड बॉक्स के लिए
हम मैनुअली उसमें स्टेप्स लेंगे। तो हम
इसको एक मैनुअल प्रोसेस में डाल देते हैं।
अब ये सही होना चाहिए। इसमें एरर नहीं आनी
चाहिए। रेपेटेशन चेक्स में नहीं आनी
चाहिए। यस नहीं आई। तो इनके हिसाब से देखो
ट्राई एकक में बहुत सारी ऐसी चीजें होती
हैं। इनके हिसाब से कुछ चीजें करोगे तो वो
सही होंगी। बट हो सकता है कि कुछ चीजें जो
आप कर रहे हो वो भी सही है। तो यहां पे
रेपुटेशन चेक्स में हमने ये ऑटोमेटेड और
दो मैनुअल यहां पे कर दिया है। अब यहां
कोर्स ऑफ़ एक्शन का इशू आ रहा है। तो भैया
यहां पे क्या इशू आ रहा है? ब्लॉक डोमेन
ऑटोमेटेड है। ब्लॉक आईपी ऑटोमेटेड है।
ब्लॉक यूआरएल ऑटोमेटेड है। इसमें भी कोई
टेंशन नहीं है। तीनों सही है। अपडेट केस
टिकट्स। तो ये ऑटोमेटेड है। इसको हम केस
टिकट को अपडेट करने का मैनुअल को ऑटोमेटेड
कर देते हैं। और एनालिस्ट वाला मैनुअल
रखते हैं। ठीक है? बस ये करते हैं और रन
पे क्लिक करते हैं। ये लो कंप्लीट हो गई।
एंड यहां पे आपके पास आ गया। उसमें एक
मैनुअल था लास्ट वाला। बाकी सारे ऑटोमेटेड
और यहां पे आपको फ्लैग मिल गया और फ्लैग
को यहां डालेंगे। यह लैब सॉल्व हो जाएगा।
तो इस तरीके से आपका ये एक एनालिटिकल
स्किल जो है वो थोड़ा सा मतलब एनहांस हुआ
है यहां पे। आपको पता चला एग्जैक्टली कि
कौन सा चीज ऑटोमेटेड है। कौन सा चीज
मैनुअल है। किस तरीके की चीजों को हम कर
सकते हैं। ये एक तरह का वर्क फ्ल्लो।
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस वर्क फ्लो आपने देखा है।
ठीक है? थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस वर्क फ्ल्लो ऐसे
ही काम करता है। अभी कोई पूछ रहा था सर
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस कवर होगा कि नहीं? इतना
इन डेप्थ की जरूरत नहीं होती है। जितना
जरूरत है हम सब कवर करते ही चलेंगे। उसकी
बेफिक्र आपको रहना है। ठीक है? बिल्कुल
बेफिक्र रहना है। तो यहां पे वी डिड अ
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस वर्क फ्लो प्रैक्टिकल
जहां पे एक डेमोंस्ट्रेशन हैंड्स ऑन हमने
किया एंड उसमें हमने देखा कि कैसे आप
अलग-अलग कंडीशंस को ऑटोमेट या मैनुअल में
डिवाइड करते हो एंड उनको बफरकेट करके एंड
समझ लेते हो। आई थिंक आपको समझ में आ चुका
होगा ये। राइट? सभी को समझ में आया? यह जो
स्टेप्स हमने किए जो सॉल्व किया हमने डिड
यू अंडरस्टैंड गाइज़ लेट मी नो जल्दी बताइए
सभी लोग
एवरीबडी और लाइक ठोका नहीं हुआ तो लाइक
ठोक देना सभी क्योंकि आज लाइक्स कम है 100
लाइक्स भी नहीं है आज सो लाइक ठोक देने का
ठीक है
हां ऑटोमेटेड करोगे सही होगा कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है क्लियर है
ओके [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ओके बहुत
बढ़िया क्लियर है तो बहुत अच्छी बात है।
वेरी गुड
ठीक है। चलिए बढ़िया। अब यहां पे आ जाते
हैं टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट में। आज की सेशन
यहीं पे आपकी इतनी ही थी। आज की सेशन
थोड़ी छोटी थी। आप लोग चाहते भी हैं छोटा
सेशन तो आपके अकॉर्डिंग आज का सेशन हो
गया। टॉप फेंस की लिस्ट में जाते हैं।
यहां पे टॉफेंस की लिस्ट देख लेते हैं। यह
हमारा टॉफेंस की लिस्ट है। दिस इज़ वही
सारे लोग हैं जो रहते हैं जनरली। एज़ आई
कैन सी दैट्स ग्रेट। अभी तक कंटिन्यूड हैं
ये लोग। एंड इतने टाइम बाद भी अगर दे आर
कंटिन्यूइंग एंड कमिंग देन इट्स अ गुड
थिंग। अच्छी बात है आपके लिए अच्छा है।
एंड थैंक यू वेरी मच गाइस
इतना प्यार सपोर्ट यह सब चीजें देने के
लिए। साथ ही में इस ट्रेनिंग की वैल्यू को
समझिएगा। ऐसी ट्रेनिंग आपको नहीं मिलेगा।
वैसे जनरली मैं सच बता रहा हूं। कई जगह पे
पैसे देंगे फंस के उसके बाद भी नहीं
मिलेगा। बट यहां आपको मिल रहा है। तो जस्ट
यूटिलाइज़ दिस जस्ट यूटिलाइज़ इन अ
बेनिफिशियल मोर बेनिफिशियल वे जो आपके
करियर के लिए अच्छा होगा। एंड जब आपकी जॉब
लग जाएगी तो काफी मजा आएगा। आई होप कि आप
में से मैक्सिमम लोगों की जॉब लगे जिनको
जॉब चाहिए। राइट? या फिर जिनको नॉलेज के
लिए भी कर रहे हैं उनकी नॉलेज एनहांस हो
अच्छे तरीके से। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सो दिस वाज़ ऑल
फॉर टुडे सेशन। आज की सेशन आपकी लगभग डेढ़
घंटे की हुई है। आप काफी खुश होंगे आप तो
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] ठीक
है।
हां, अभी तक आपको जितना पता है उसमें आप
थोड़ी बहुत और एक्सप्लोर करके खुद से
इंटरव्यूज के लिए जा तो सकते हैं। बट मैं
यही बोलूंगा कि जब पूरी खत्म हो जाए तो
जाए तो ज्यादा बेटर होगा शायद। बट अगर आप
खुद से भी थोड़ी जो बची हुई टॉपिक्स है
अगर आप कर सकते हैं या थोड़ी खुद से
एक्सप्लोर करके इंटरव्यू क्वेश्चंस को देख
के अगर जाना चाहे इंटरव्यू के लिए तो आप
जा सकते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम ऐसी नहीं है।
ऐसा नहीं है कि आपको बिल्कुल समझ नहीं
आएगा। बिल्कुल आपको बहुत कुछ ऑलरेडी पता
चल चुका है। बाकी और चीजें हैं क्लासेस
हैं वो जल्दी खत्म हो जाएंगी। फिर तो आप
एलिजिबल है ही। ठीक है? दैट्स इट। आई होप
यू गॉट इट। राइट?
मजा आया ना? चलिए अच्छी बात है। अच्छी बात
है। मजा आया तो बहुत अच्छी बात है। आज का
सेशन गाइस थोड़ा सा छोटा था। एंड
आई वुड
कम सून इन द नेक्स्ट सेशन। कमेंट कर
दीजिएगा। 100 कमेंट्स आप लोग तो फुल भी
नहीं करते हैं। फिर भी मैं ला ही दे रहा
हूं क्लासेस। बट प्लीज उसको कंप्लीट
कीजिए। 100 कमेंट्स करना आपके लिए
मैंडेटरी है। आपको मैं अगर बोल रहा हूं तो
यू शुड बी डूइंग दैट। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] थैंक यू वेरी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मच। थैंक यू
वेरी मच गाइस। एंड चलिए आज के सेशन को बस
यहीं पे एंड करते हैं। एंड थैंक यू वेरी
मच एवरीबॉडी फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन। जल्दी
नेक्स्ट क्लास में मिलेंगे नए टॉपिक के
साथ। इसको वापस रिवाइज कीजिएगा। हाइप कर
दीजिएगा वीडियो को। जब आप वीडियो देखने
जाएंगे तो हाइप का बटन होता है ताकि
YouTube उसको सजेस्ट करेगी अलग-अलग
तरीकों से। जितनी हाइप करेंगे आप जितने
हाइप पॉइंट्स होते हैं उतने ज्यादा
YouTube उसको सजेस्ट और रिकमेंड करता है।
तो वीडियो उतनी जगह जाती है और शेयर
कीजिएगा वीडियो को अपने दोस्तों के साथ,
अपने कलीग्स के साथ जो भी इंटरेस्टेड हैं
एसओसी इन सब में। राइट? तो प्लीज ये सारी
चीजें कर दीजिएगा। ठीक है? बस दैट्स इट
गाइस फॉर टुडे सेशन। थैंक यू वेरी मच एंड
गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
अपकमिंग क्लास में बहुत जल्द इसके नेक्स्ट
क्लास में। एंड डीएचई की सीरीज ऑलरेडी
रिज्यूम हो चुकी है। तो प्लीज आप लोग
डीएचई की सीरीज भी देखिएगा। एथिकल हैकिंग
की बहुत ही शानदार क्लासेस होती हैं और
बहुत कुछ आने वाला है। एक एथिकल हैकिंग की
फुल कोर्स 5 घंटे की लगभग हम लेकर आने
वाले हैं फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट। एक साथ डलेगी
आपकी। मजा आएगा आपको देख के। तो देयर आर
लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग्स दैट इज़ गोइंग टू कम ऑन द
चैनल। सो सारी चीज़ आप देखते रहिएगा। चलिए
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एसओसी क्लास में गाइस।
ठीक है? थैंक यू वेरी मच। टाटा बाय बाय।